THIS IS THE TIME SET FOR THE
SENATE THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY.
WE I BELIEVE WILL BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JACKSON HERE JACKSON HERE
BORDERS.
BORDERS HERE ALLEN.
ALLEN HERE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO HERE MONNING
[inaudible]
STERN.
STERN HERE BURKE.
NUMBER HERE WHITE HOUSE SKI.
ALRIGHT A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ARE TO HAVE SOME CHANGES TO
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUTIN WELCOME ERICA
PORTER ARE WHO IS NOW OUR LEAD
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT AFTER
SERVING. FOR THREE YEARS AS OUR
BACKUP COMMITTEE ASSISTANT AND
WE HAVE WITH US NOW KEVIN SORBO.
WHO JOINED US MONDAY?
AS OUR NEW BACKUP COMMITTEE
ASSISTANT HE COMES TO US FROM
THE ASSEMBLY SPEAKERS OFFICE OF
RESEARCH.
AND FLOOR ANALYSIS WELCOME KEVIN
NOON GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON PROPOSED
CONSENT.
THEY ARE FILE ITEM TO SB SIXTY
BY SENATOR ATKINS FILE ITEM SIX
SB THREE OH NINE BY SENATOR
JONES WITH AMENDMENTS. THREE OH
EIGHT EXCUSE ME THREE OH EIGHT
BY THE CENTER JONES WITH
AMENDMENTS AND FILE ITEM.
SEVEN SB THREE ONE FOUR THREE
FOURTEEN BY SENATOR DODD IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOTION.
BY THE COMMITTEE -- PLEASE THE
MRS MS COMMITTEE ASSISTANCE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN I COVER EURO [inaudible]
I MONNING [inaudible]
STERN.
STERN AYE UMBERG.
UMBERG BY WHITE HOUSE SKI.
ALL RIGHTS WE HAVE -- FIVE OR
SIX VOTES AND WE WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN TO THE
MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
THEY ARE HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE
IN FILE ORDER.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THAT FOR
EACH MEASURE THERE BE TWO MAIN
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH FOR
SUPPORT AND THEN SIMILARLY. TO
THE MAIN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
AND AT THAT POINT TO AFTER WE
HEAR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
AND WE'VE HAD OUR TWO WITNESSES
TWO MINUTES EACH WILL ASK ANY
OTHER PEOPLE HERE IN SUPPORT THE
POLICE STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE
GIVE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND INDICATE VERY
BRIEFLY YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
ITEM AND THE SAME WE WILL DO
WITH THE OPPOSITION WHEN THE
TERM.
A TIME COMES FOR THAT TO BE
HEARD SO THE FIRST MEASURE TODAY
THAT WE WILL BE HEARING IS SB.
THIRTY FILE ITEM ONE BY SENATOR
WIENER THE DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP --
BILL.
AND DOES MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE HAS BEEN NO OPPOSITION.
A TIMELY FILED TO THIS MEASURE.
AND THAT -- SENATOR WINNER YOU
WILL BE TAKING THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS ON PAGE
FIFTEEN COLLEAGUES.
IN COMMON NUMBER NINE IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT VERY GOOD
A GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR WIENER
YOU MAY PROCEED I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING DILIGENTLY --
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT -- SO --
COLORS THIS IS A A BILL -- TO
INSURE THAT WE HAVE FULL EQUAL
TREATMENT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHEN IT COMES TO CALIFORNIA'S.
A DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP A
REGISTRY.
THE NICER PARTNERSHIP REGISTRY
WAS CREATED -- BACK WHEN.
LGBT PEOPLE COULD NOT LEGALLY
GET MARRIED IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
CREATED A SEPARATE FORM OF REYES
RELATIONSHIP RECOGNITION IN THE
FORM OF THE MASSIVE PARTNERSHIP.
FOR SAME SEX COUPLES.
WHICH WAS ALSO EXTENDED TO
OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES -- AGE
SIXTY TWO AN OLDER -- FOR
REASONS OF SOCIAL SECURITY.
NOW WE HAVE FOR MARRIAGE
EQUALITY IN CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONALLY OF COURSE FIVE AND
BUT BUT THE DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP
REGISTRY CONTINUES TO EXCLUDE --
OPPOSITE GENDER COUPLES UNDER
THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO THERE'S NO
RATIONAL.
BASIS FOR THAT -- AND WE SHOULD
BE EXTENDING -- THIS CHOICE --
TO EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION GENDER IT CETERA --
AND IN OUR MODERN SOCIETY PEOPLE
MAKE A LOT OF DIFFERENT CHOICES
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP SOME
PEOPLE WANT TO GET MARRIED.
SOME PEOPLE DON'T SOME PEOPLE I
PREFER NOT TO GET MARRIED BUT
STILL WANT TO HAVE A BASIC LEVEL
OF RELATIONSHIP.
PROTECTION PROTECTION FOR THEIR
CHILDREN -- AND SO IT MAKES
SENSE FOR TO PASS THIS BILL AND
TO EXTEND DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
HI TO ALL CALIFORNIANS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE --
AND WITH THE TODAY'S TIME MARTIN
FROM QUALITY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- TAMMY
MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA SERVING THE
STATE'S LGBT Q. POPULATION.
AND WE'RE PROUD SUPPORTERS OF SB
THIRTY WHICH REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S RESPECT FOR THE
VALUES AND LONG TERM PLANS OF
ITS DIVERSE POPULATION.
AND PROVIDES GREATER FREEDOM THE
FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS.
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA LED THE WAY
IN OUR STATE'S QUEST TO ACHIEVE
MARRIAGE EQUALITY FOR SAME SEX
COUPLES.
AND AS PART OF THAT WORK THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT HELD
THAT STATE LAWS SHOULDN'T TREAT
PEOPLE DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
THEREFORE CALIFORNIA'S DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP REGISTRY IS OUTDATED.
AND SHOULD NO LONGER BE ONLY
AVAILABLE TO SAME SEX COUPLES OR
OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES OVER AGE
SIXTY TWO IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO ALL COUPLES.
AND NOT EVERYONE WISHES TO ENTER
INTO MARRIAGE BUT ALL COUPLES
SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS AND FAMILIES
RECOGNIZED AND PROTECTED.
SB THIRTY HELP THEM DO THAT.
SERVER THESE REASONS EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS SB THIRTY
AND URGES THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU
WOULD STEP FORWARD.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
SPIRALING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARY HYATT FROM CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DIET SHOULD THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
SENATOR BORCHERS.
THE CATCHER ONE APPRECIATED.
GLOW IN APPRECIATED CHAD JUST A
MOMENT AGO -- WANTED JUST KIND
OF CONFIRM IN THE RECORD THAT --
FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO COULD BE
MISLED -- BY JUST THE THE
SYMBOLISM ATTACHED.
TO ALL THESE DIFFERENT
DESIGNATIONS ARE ONLY SIR WE
KIND OF CUT THROUGH THAT -- AND
GET THE HEART OF THE MATTER
[inaudible]
SO -- HETEROSEXUAL COUPLES HAVE
THE OPTION OF MARRIAGE.
HOMOSEXUAL COUPLES HAVE THE
OPTION ARE FOR DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIPS -- HETEROSEXUAL
COUPLES WERE ALLOWED TO HAVE
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS IF THEY
WERE OVER SIXTY OF ONE OF THOSE
OVER -- SIXTY TWO SO.
UNLESS I'M MISTAKEN THIS IS
ALMOST LIKE AN INVERSE EQUAL
PROTECTION ISSUE.
THAT YOU'RE ENABLING
HETEROSEXUAL COUPLES TO HAVE THE
SAME PROTECTIONS THAT HOMOSEXUAL
COUPLES HAVE FOR ANY VARIETY OF
REASON WITH TAX REASONS --
PROPERTY -- SUCCESSION ISSUES --
IS THAT A FAIR -- FRAMEWORK OF
THE ISSUES YEAH YES WE WANT TO
MAKE.
SURE OF THAT -- THAT
HETEROSEXUAL -- PEOPLE UNDER THE
AGE OF SIXTY TO HAVE THE SAME
ABILITY TO ACCESS MISTER
PARTNERSHIPS AS LGBT PEOPLE OR
PEOPLE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO
OKAY.
I WILL MAKE CERTAIN THAT YOU
KNOW IF ANYONE'S LISTENING TO
THIS THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
VIRTUE OF THE SANCTITY OF
MARRIAGE THIS IS ABOUT THIS IS A
LEGAL ISSUE THIS IS ABOUT.
EQUAL PROTECTION FOR THOSE
COUPLES THAT WISH TO MAINTAIN A
UNION OUTSIDE OF MARRIAGE BUT
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS.
APPROVED FOR THEIR OWN PRIVATE
PERSONAL REASONS -- WANT TO HAVE
THEIR RIGHTS PROTECTED FOR THOSE
UNDER SIX SIXTY TWO RIGHT AND
AND IN FACT WE'VE ALREADY MADE
THE POLICY CHOICE THAT
HETEROSEXUAL COUPLES SIXTY TWO
AND OLDER.
CAN BE DOMESTIC PARTNER BECAUSE
PRESUMABLY AS I UNDERSTAND IT
BECAUSE OF NOT WANTING TO
FORFEIT SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS.
SO WE'VE ALREADY MADE THE CHOICE
TO GIVE SOME OPPOSITE SEX
COUPLES.
DID ACCESS TO MR PARTNERSHIPS --
WE WANT TO GIVE ALL OF THEM THAT
OPTION OKAY THIS IS THE TO BE AN
EQUAL PROTECTION ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT CLARIFIES
SHOULDN'T I DO THINK THAT WAS
THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATION.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MOTION BY SENATOR STERN SEEING
NO OTHER COMMENTS THOSE SENATOR
WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL THE
GREAT CLOSE VERY GOOD.
MADAM SECRETARY THE MEASURE IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL JACKSON HI
JACKSON AYE FORGES.
OR JUST AYE ALAN.
ALLEN I COVER HERO.
HI MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN AYE UMBERG [inaudible]
WHITE HOUSE.
THE VOTE THE IS SIX TWO ZERO WE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR
WIENER.
OUR NEXT ITEM UP IS FILE ITEM
THREE SENATOR MITCHELL SP ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT ON DISCRIMINATION
AND HAIRSTYLES.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR LONG TIME NO SEE.
pTODAY PRESIDING THIS BILL FIRST
SITS.
TO EDUCATE PERHAPS MANY VIEW
ABOUT THE UNIQUENESS OF BLACK
HEARING THE UNIQUENESS OF OUR
TEXTURE.
AND IT'S THAT CHALLENGE FROM
COMMON HELD MYTHS ABOUT WHAT
CONSTITUTES PROFESSIONALISM IN
THE WORKPLACE.
WE'RE GONNA DO THAT TODAY
THROUGH OUR BILL SB ONE EIGHT
EIGHT THE CROWN ACT WHICH WE
HOPE WILL CREATE A RESPECTFUL
AND OPEN WORKPLACE FOR NATURAL
HAIR.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN A
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN HAD
HIS LOCKS VIOLENTLY CUT.
BY AN OFFICIAL IN THE MIDDLE OF
A WRESTLING TOURNAMENT.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
AND I EXPECT MANY OF US IN THIS
VERY ROOM WATCH THAT VIDEO
FOOTAGE.
IT'S VISCERAL EMOTIONAL AND
DEVASTATING FOR THE YOUNG MAN.
AND ALL WHO WITNESSED IT.
ON THAT DAY WHICH I'M SURE HE IN
THIS FAMILY WILL REMEMBER FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIFE.
THE REFEREE ALLEN MALONEY GAVE
THE CHILD AN ULTIMATUM.
LOSE YOUR HAIR.
AND WITH THAT YOUR PERSONALLY
RACIAL IDENTITY.
AND DIGNITY OR LOSE THE MATCH.
LEADING HIS TEAM COACH AND
SCHOOL DOWN.
IT WAS LATER DETERMINED BECAUSE
THAT WASN'T THE FIRST TIME HE'S
WRESTLED ON THE AFTER THE SCHOOL
THAT THERE IS HEAD GAR THAT CAN
BE WORN.
THAT MANY ATHLETES WHERE -- TO
COVER THEIR HERE AND THAT
REFEREE FOR WHATEVER REASON
CHOSE TO NOT ALLOW HIM TO WEAR
THE HEAD GEAR.
AND REQUIRED THAT HIS LOCKS.
AT THE MOMENT BE CUT.
WITHOUT ANY CONSULTATION WITH
HIS PARENTS.
HE WON THE MATCH.
BUT SOMEWHAT ARGUE THIS
PERSONALIZED ENTITY.
WITH CALLED INTO QUESTION.
THAT'S A SITUATION THAT NO
PARENT WOULD WANT TO FORCE IN
THEIR CHILD AND CERTAINLY NO
TEACHER COACH OR MENTOR EVER
SHOULD.
IT WAS SHOCKING FOR ME TO
WITNESS.
AND THAT CERTAINLY WAS NOT THE
FIRST TIME A PERSON OF COLOR IN
AMERICA WAS FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THEIR RACIAL OR ETHNIC
IDENTITY.
AND THEIR ACADEMIC OR
PROFESSIONAL ADVANCEMENT.
THERE ARE MANY CASES OF BLACK
EMPLOYEES AND APPLICANTS DENIED
EMPLOYMENT OR PROMOTION AND EVEN
TERMINATED BECAUSE OF EITHER
THEIR CORN ROLLS BRAIDS OR LOCK.
I HAVE HEARD HEART BREAKING
REPORTS OF YOUNG BLACK GIRLS
HUMILIATED AND SENT HOME FROM
SCHOOL.
BECAUSE THEIR HAIR WAS DEAN TO
CALL ON THE RULING AND A
DISTRACTION TO OTHERS.
CAN WE TRULY SAY EQUITY EXISTS
WHEN OUR CHILDREN ARE DENIED THE
RIGHT TO REMAIN IN CLASS AND
LEARN BECAUSE THE
CHARACTERISTICS NATURAL
CHARACTERISTICS OF THEIR HAIR.
WHERE IS THE JUSTICE WHEN BLACK
MEN AND WOMEN ARE DENIED ACCESS
TO ECONOMIC ADVANCEMENT?
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEY CHOOSE
TO WEAR THEIR HAIR.
HERE -- CENTRIC STANDARDS OF
BEAUTY HAVE HELD THE
UNDERPINNINGS OF AMERICAN
CULTURE SINCE THE FOUNDING OF
OUR SOCIETY.
DETERMINING AND INFORMING WHAT
WAS ACCEPTABLE AND ATTRACTIVE IN
THE MEDIA ACADEMIC SETTINGS AND
THAT WORK. FOR THE PURPOSE OF SB.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT IS TO
COLLECTIVELY DEFINE AND PROTECT
WHAT WE'RE CALLING PROTECTIVE
HERE.
BRAIDS LOCKS OR TWO WITH.
BECAUSE WE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO WEAR OUR HAIR AS WE CHOOSE.
THE COURT IN E. E. O. C. VERSUS.
A CATASTROPHE MANAGEMENT
SOLUTIONS IN ROGERS VERSES
AMERICAN AIRLINES INC IN PIP'S
VERSES WILD ADVENTURES INK AND
MANY OTHER CASES HAVE RULE TO
ALLOW.
WORKPLACE DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
ANY PRESENTATION OF NATURAL HAIR
THAT IS NOT AN AFRO AN AFRO IS
CURRENTLY A PROTECTED CATEGORY.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT TRULY
DISTRACTING HAIRSTYLES.
DEPENDS ON YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
COLOR RAINBOW COLORED DRESSES OR
PEAK MOHAWKS WERE SPEAKING OF
GROOMED HAIR STYLES LIKE MY
LOCKS THAT WOULD WITHOUT
QUESTION FIT AN IMAGE OF
PROFESSIONALISM.
IF BIAS OR NEGATIVE STEREO TYPES
WERE NOT INVOLVED.
DO YOU SUPPOSE THAT RACE NEUTRAL
WORKPLACE GREEN POLICIES THAT
BAND BRAIDS TWIST CORALS UNLOCKS
MAY APPLY TO EMPLOYEES OR
APPLICANTS OF ALL RACES HOWEVER
THEY HAVE A DISPARATE IMPACT ON
BLACK MEN AND WOMEN.
THIS MEANS THESE POLICIES ARE
FAR MORE LIKELY TO EXCLUDE
BLACKS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
WORKPLACE THE PEOPLE OF ANY
OTHER RACE.
MANY BLACK EMPLOYEES WILL TELL
YOU IF GIVEN THE CHANCE THAT THE
STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN WHAT
SOCIETY IS DEEMED A PROFESSIONAL
IMAGE WHILE PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND INTEGRITY OF THEIR
HERE REMAINS A DEFINING AND
pWORK EXPERIENCE.
NOT USUALLY SHARED BY THEIR NON
BLACK PEERS.
BLACK EMPLOYEES SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO CONFORM TO A NON INCLUSIVE
IDEA OF A PROFESSIONAL IMAGE AT
THE EXPENSE OF THEIR PERSONAL
CHOICE CHOICE OR EVEN THE HEALTH
OF THEIR HERE.
IT'S TWENTY NINETEEN AT ANY LAW
THAT SANCTIONS THE JOB
DESCRIPTION THAT IMMEDIATELY
EXCLUDES ME FROM A POSITION.
OR ANYONE ELSE THAT CHOOSES TO
WEAR THEIR HAIR THIS NATIONAL
FORM NOT BECAUSE OF MY CAPACITY
TO DO THE JOB BECAUSE OF HOW I
CHOOSE TO WEAR MY HAIR.
IS LONG OVERDUE FOR REFORM.
I HAVE HERE WITH ME TODAY.
PROFESSOR WINDY GREEN FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
LAW IN ALABAMA.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY A LICENSED.
COSMETOLOGIST AKELA HATS FALL
WHO OWNS A SALON HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND WHOSE ENTIRE
CLIENTELE OR PEOPLE CHOOSE TO
WEAR THEIR HAIR NATURALLY.
LET ME SAY THAT WENDY IS THE
LEADING EXPERT ON HERE
DISCRIMINATION CASES AND WAS
QUOTED IN THE EOC VERSUS CMS
COURT OPINION.
I ASKED THAT TELL YOU GIVE THEM
THE TIME A LOT OF TO SPEAK AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ON SB.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL GOOD AFTERNOON
WELCOME AND IF YOU WOULD TO
LIMIT YOUR REMARKS TWO TWO
MINUTES EACH OF HER QUESTIONS WE
WILL THEN.
PROCEED TO ASK THEM GOOD
AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
WENDY GREEN AND I AM A LEADING
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAW SCHOLAR
TEACHER AN ADVOCATE I GRADUATED
FROM XAVIER UNIVERSITY OF
LOUISIANA -- WITH AN HONORS IN
ENGLISH AND A DOUBLE MINOR IN
AFRICA AMERICAN STUDIES AS WELL
WELL AS SPANISH I ALSO EARNED BY
JURIS DOCTORATE FROM TULANE
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW AND A
MASTERS OF LAW DEGREE FROM THE
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY
SCHOOL OF LAW.
WHERE SPECIALIZED IN COMPARED OF
SLAVERY AND RACE RELATIONS AND
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION LAW?
I HAVE SPENT MUCH OF MY CAREER
AS A LW PROFESSOR AND SCHOLAR
ADVOCATING FOR GREATER AWARENESS
AROUND IN CIVIL PROTECTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO SUFFER
DISCRIMINATION DUE TO THESE
UNCHECKED DISCRIMINATORY GROWING
POLICIES.
AND WORKPLACES AND BEYOND NAMELY
POLICIES THAT STIGMATIZE NATURAL
HAIRSTYLES AS UNPROFESSIONAL
DISTRACTING EXTREME EXCESSIVE IN
ON CAN'T POLICIES THAT REQUIRE
AFRICAN DISSIDENTS TO CUT OFF
THEIR HERE SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE
WAY IT NATURALLY GROWS.
OR IN THE CASES OF AFRICAN
DESCENT IT WOMEN AND GIRLS.
GROOMING POLICIES THAT REQUIRE
THAT THEY DON STREET HERE
USUALLY ACHIEVED THROUGH TOXIC
CHEMICALS EXTREME HEAT STYLING
WEEKS AND WEEKS WHICH ARE OFTEN
TIMES EXPENSIVE AND TIME
CONSUMING TO MAINTAIN.
MORE OVER THE OFTEN RESULT IN
PERMANENT HAIR AND SCALP DAMAGE
AS WELL AS PERMANENTLY AND OR
TEMPORARY HERE LOS.
NATURAL HAIR BANDS LEAVE AFRICAN
DESCENT AT WOMEN AND GIRLS IN A
PRECARIOUS CATCH TWENTY TWO
EITHER DON YOUR NATURAL HAIR AT
THE RISK OF LAWFULLY.
BEING DEPRIVED OF AN EMPLOYMENT
OF EMPLOYMENT AND OR AN
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY OR DON
STRAIGHT HERE AT THE RISK OF AN
DURING CONSEQUENTIAL HARMS TO
YOUR PSYCHOLOGICAL PHYSICAL IN
FACT IN PHYSIOLOGICAL WELL BEING.
AS A SENATOR MITCHELL MITCHELL
MENTIONED MUCH OF MY SCHOLARSHIP
AND BECAUSE HE HAS FOCUSED ON
CRITIQUING FEDERAL COURT
DECISIONS THAT FAIL TO TREAT
WORKPLACE BANS GAINST AFRICAN
DESCENDANTS.
NATURAL HAIR STYLES AS RACE
DISCRIMINATION AND THIS IS
LARGELY DUE TO AN APPLICATION OF
AN OUTDATED -- RULE CALLED
IMMUTABILITY DOCTRINE AND I I
CAN SAVE THAT FOR LATER IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
BUT UNDER THAT DOCTRINE A
SENATOR MITCHELL MENTION OF
FEDERAL COURTS HAVE PROCLAIMED
THAT AFTER OWES ART IN IMMUTABLE
RACIAL CHARACTERISTIC.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS HAIR
SPLITTING DISTINCTION IT
ENGENDERS AN UNJUSTIFIABLE
OUTCOME IF AN EMPLOYER DENIES AN
AFRICAN DESCENDED A JOB BECAUSE
SHE ADORNS AN AFRO.
THE EMPLOYER ENGAGES IN UNLAWFUL
RACE DISCRIMINATION HOW OLD
HOWEVER THE MOMENT THAT SAME
EMPLOYEE TWIST LOCKS OR BRAIDS
HER AFRO AND SUFFERS ADVERSE
TREATMENT ON THOSE GROUNDS.
THE EMPLOYERS DISCRIMINATION IS
DEEMED LAWFUL AND BEYOND THE
SCOPE SCOPE OF FEDERAL CIVIL
RIGHTS STATUTES.
AND WHAT THIS PARTICULAR BILL
DOES IS IT FEELS THE GAP HERE
WITH RESPECT TO PROTECTION FOR
RACE DISCRIMINATION PLAINTIFFS
IN THESE GROOMING CODES CASES.
AND AND SO BASED ON CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY OF STANDING STRONG AND
IT'S PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL THERE
REALLY IS NO BETTER STATE TO NOT
ONLY HAVE THIS DISCUSSION BUT
ALSO TO TAKE MEANINGFUL ACTION
TOWARD CORRECTING.
THIS INEQUALITY UNDER THE LAW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
TESTIMONY NEXT WITNESS TWO
MINUTES PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
KILLER HATCHET FALL.
ON THE OWNER AND OPERATOR OF
SACRED CROWNS BRIDGES DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO I HAVE A THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CLIENTS AND
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING FOR THIRTY
PLUS YEARS.
OF THIS.
OUR HAIR IS MORE THAN A
HAIRSTYLE IT IS A LIFESTYLE.
AND WITHOUT BE IN AND I HAVE HAD
NUMEROUS TIMES WHERE PEOPLE COME
IN AND SAID I'VE GOT TO GET A
JOB.
I'VE BEEN OUT TO SEVERAL
INTERVIEWS AND HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GET A JOB SO I'VE HAD TO
CUT THEIR LOCKS OFF.
OR CUT OFF THEIR HERE IN SOME
NATURAL WAYS SO THAT THEY AGO
AND DAMAGE THEIR HERE BY DOING
PERMITS OR OTHER.
OF THERMAL TEXT ARISING OR
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY CAUSE PROBLEMS FOR THEM
LATER ON AND THEY STILL TO GET
THE JOB.
SO I REALLY THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE REALLY LOOK AT
THIS BECAUSE OF IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO EVERYONE TO
BE ABLE TO ATTRIBUTE.
A WHOLE THEY ARE ARE HERE FOR
MANY YEARS GENERATIONS CENTURIES
ARE HERE IS WHAT IS DEFINED AS
AFRICAN PEOPLE -- AND THAT IS
WHERE IN OUR HAIR IS MORE THAN A
HAIRSTYLE IT ACTUALLY DENOTES
WHO WE ARE IN AFRICA TO NOTABLE
TRIBES WE'RE FROM.
IT'S NOT A WHOLE WHAT KIND OF
JOB WE HAVE WHAT KIND OF FAMILY
WERE FROM SO IT HAS NOT CHANGED
THAT IS ONE THING ABOUT OUR
CULTURE.
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SURVIVE
THROUGH THE FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
OF OPPRESSION AND BEING
SUBJECTED TO WHITE SUPREMACY AS
WELL AS EURO CENTRIC STANDARDS
OF BEAUTY.
SO BEING ABLE TO WEAR OUR HAIR
NATURAL IS IMPORTANT.
I DEAL WITH THIS EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN TERMS OF PEOPLE HAVING
OTHER HAIR DONE NATURAL -- A
COSMETOLOGIST BY TRADE AS WELL
AS A LOT TUITION UNLOCKED AS IN
THE SOMEONE WHO LOCKS OR TWISTS
OR BRAIDS NATURAL HAIR.
AND IT'S WONDERFUL FOR PEOPLE IS
MORE THAN WHEN THEY COME IN TO
GET THEIR HAIR LOT THEY NOT ONLY
DO PART WORRY ABOUT THEM NOT
ONLY LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE HERE
IS GOING TO DO.
NATURALLY BUT IT ENDS UP
INTERNALLY IT TURNS ON SOMETHING
IN THEM.
AND THAT ACTUALLY GETS THEM TO
INTERNAL Là INTERNALLY -- FIND
OUT MORE AND BLOSSOM FOR WHO
THEY ACTUALLY ARE AS A PEOPLE SO
BEING ABLE TO OF SO NOT BEING
ABLE. TO TO DO THAT AND GET A
JOB OR NOT B. AND PROMISED A JOB
IS JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT --
IT'S BEEN A PRACTICE BUT IT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
BE SUBJECTED.
TO THINK AND I CAN ANSWER MORE
QUESTIONS IF YOU OUR PRE SHE'D
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN SUPPORT IF YOU WOULD
JUST COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE IN COME UP.
BUT ONE BEHIND THE OTHERS WELL.
THE EMBARRASSED ON BEHALF OF THE
CROWN COALITION THE CROWN
COALITION IS MADE UP OF THE
NATIONAL URBAN LEAGUE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY COLOR
OF CHANGE AND OF WE ARE A
NATIONAL ALLIANCE THAT IS
DEDICATED TO IT DANCING ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LEGISLATION
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
TODAY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AJ
WILL BOOTS WE ARE SOME OUR AND
ON BEHALF OF DELTA SIGMA THETA
SORORITY INCORPORATED WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
VERY CARE SHE HIGHER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IS ONE OF THINK THE
AUTHOR NOW BECAUSE FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BACK A KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CARE HARRIS OF SYSTEMS AGING
WITH GRACE AND ELEGANCE WE ARE
AN AGENCY THAT PROMOTES HEALTHY
AGING FOR BLACK WOMEN AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE MANY OF US.
PREFER TO WEAR HERE NATURALLY.
I'M JEALOUS THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JAMES SWEENEY.
I'M WITH THE BLACK AMERICAN
POLITICAL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY AND FOR RIDLEY.
SEE YOUR AYE VOTE AND WE HOPE
THAT YOU ALL WILL.
SUPPORT OUR CULTURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BAMBOO BOND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S BANK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR FLOWS ON
CO FIRST SENIOR DIRECTOR OF
POLICY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES A WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ROOM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DONNA
WOULD I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF NEGRO WOMEN
SACRAMENTO VALLEY SECTION WE
PROBABLY AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
I AM VICKI BOYD AND I AM WITH
AND WITH THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
NEGRO WOMEN AND ALSO BAY PACK
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEDI HIRED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CIVIL LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ON MY CHANNEL WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY ONE OFTHE CO SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
[inaudible]
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
EXCELLENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS -- THAT ACTUALLY IS
A PERFECT SEGUE -- THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY IT TAKES A LOOK AT
THOSE SITUATIONS IN THE
EMPLOYMENT ARENA AND I AM
WONDERING I THINK WE CHATTED
ABOUT THIS IF YOU WOULD -- TO
CONSIDER IF SOME ADVOCATES HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT PERHAPS THE
BILL SHOULD BE EXPANDED TO COVER
SCHOOLS AS WELL.
HAVE YOU GIVEN THOUGHT TO THAT
ABSOLUTELY WE'VE GOT DRAFT
LANGUAGE I BELIEVE BACK FROM
COUNCIL -- WE WANTED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATION WITH SOME OF THE
EDUCATION NOW -- STAKEHOLDERS I
WAS GLAD TO HEAR -- THE THE LAST
ORGANIZATIONS EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IT'S IT'S
INTERESTING THAT THE ADULTS IN
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM TEACHERS
AND ALL WOULD BE COVERED UNDER
SB.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT IF WE DON'T
ADDRESS THE EDUCATION COLD THE
STUDENTS WOULD BE THE ONLY ONES
LEFT OUT AND SO WE ABSOLUTELY
ARE COMMITTED TO MOVING THAT
LANGUAGE FOR IT -- AND WILL BE
DOING SO.
SHE EIGHT THE EXHAUSTIVE DETAIL
INCLUDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AS WELL AS THAT --
RECOMMENDATION AND WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE ACCEPTING OF
CANDLES AMENDMENTS I THINK OF
THIS YOUNG MAN WHO WAS A
WRESTLER AND WHAT A HUMILIATING
EXPERIENCE THAT MUST'VE BEEN FOR
HIM AND I DON'T THINK ANYONE
SHOULD HAVE TO BE SUBJECTED TO
THAT SO.
I'M DELIGHTED THAT YOU ARE.
GOING TO EXPAND THE MEASURE --
AND I WOULD LIKE -- TO JUST TO
CONFIRM THE BILL STILL DOES
ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO IMPOSE
REASONABLE NON DISCRIMINATORY
GRAMMY POLICIES IS THAT CORRECT
ABSOLUTELY -- MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WORK IN FOOD SERVICE ARE YOU
WORK -- AROUND MACHINERY THAT
REQUIRES LONG HERE BE PULLED UP
OR HEARING THAT IT THIS BILL HAS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
THOSE KINDS OF WORKPLACE
APPROPRIATE -- STRATEGIES THAT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT
THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR STERN
MOVE THE BILL GOV SENATOR
CAFIERO.
MADAM CHAIR -- SENATOR YOU
INDICATED THAT YOU WANTED TO
EDUCATE US AND I THINK YOU DID A
GREAT JOB I'D LIKE TO JOIN YOU
ASA CO AUTHOR IF I APPRECIATE
THAT MADAM THANK YOU.
US SENATOR BOARD JUST.
MAYBE I'LL PERCENT OF MY
QUESTION TWO ONE TWO OUR
ACADEMIC PANELIST.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
BY THE WAY SO I KIND OF WANTED
TO GET A SENSE -- ON THE
DIVISION OF THE LINE THAT
SEPARATES RELIGIOUS EXPRESSION
OR RELIGIOUS IDENTITY FROM RACE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU KNOW IF IF
YOU WERE A SEEK.
AND YOU WERE YOUR HAIR OUT.
THAT WOULD BE PROTECTED UNDER A
RELIGIOUS EXPRESSION.
OR IF YOU WERE STATE IN AN
ACIDIC TO SAME THING RIGHT -- SO
THAT'S PROTECTED IN IN THAT AREA
BUT IN TERMS OF RACE.
THE THE GENESIS OF YOUR PROPOSAL
TODAY IS THAT IS NOT COVERED
UNDER ANY RELIGIOUS EXPRESSIONS
JUST.
BIOLOGICAL ON STYLE OF STYLE OF
HAIR AND IT'S IT'S A BIOLOGICAL
TEXTURE OF HAIR AND IT'S THE THE
POINT IS THAT I AM CHOOSING NOT
TO ARTIFICIALLY STRAIGHTEN IT.
TO KIND OF MEAT WHAT WE HAVE
THIS EXPERIENCE HISTORICALLY AS
THE YEAR OLD DEFINITION OF
WHAT'S PROFESSIONAL IN THE
WORKPLACE AND SO THE BIOLOGICAL
PIECE IS THE TEXTURE AND
CHOOSING TO WEAR MY HAIR IN ITS
NATIONAL IN ITS NATURAL FORM --
THERE BY ALLOWING ME TO USE -- A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT STYLES
LOCKS IS I WEAR MY HAIR BRAIDS
OR TWIST FILLED RACE COMES IN IN
TERMS OF THAT.
NATURAL HAIR TEXTURE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER EXAMPLES OF
TRADES HISTORICALLY ASSOCIATED
WITH RACE -- BEYOND.
THE HAIR TEXTURE AND PROTECTED
HER CELL THAT YOU CAN -- SURE --
ACTUALLY GO THERE PLENTY OF
CHARACTERISTICS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH REYES -- FOR
EXAMPLE NOT ONLY HERE TEXTURE
BUT HERE AND HERE STYLES BUT
EVEN TODAY OUR NAMES ARE SO SEAT
WITH RACE -- ALSO OUR SKIN COLOR
IS ASSOCIATE IT WITH RACE ARE NO
SHAPE IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
RACE ART THE SIZE OF OUR CHEEKS
ARE THE POINT NOUS OF OUR NOSE
OUR LIVES OUR EYES -- WE CAN GO
ON IN TERMS OF A CHARACTERISTICS
THAT HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH RACE AS WELL AS
CONTEMPORARILY ASSOCIATED WITH
RACE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SING NOW WE HAVE A MOTION
SENATOR MITCH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I'D LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE --
THE ENQUIRING YOU ALL ALLOWING
US TO HAVE THIS A VERY --
DELICATE AND POLITICAL ISSUE YOU
KNOW BLACK PEOPLE WE'VE USED OUR
HAIR OUR NATURAL HAIR -- IT'S
BEEN USED -- TO EMPOWER US AND
HAS BEEN USED AGAINST US.
MANY VIEW US WHO ARE OLD ENOUGH
TO REMEMBER -- THE BLACK POWER
MOVEMENT -- AND WHEN WE'RE IN
OUR HERE NATURAL IT AND AFRO
OLDS REALLY REFLECTED A SINCE OF
CULTURAL PRIDE -- AND I WOULD
ARGUE THAT IN MODERN TIMES WE'RE
IN OUR HERE IN ITS NATURAL STATE
OUGHT IN LOCKS IN TWIST IN
BRAIDS -- IS ONCE AGAIN BOTH A
POLITICAL AND A PERSONAL
STATEMENT A PERSONAL STATEMENT
THAT I CHOSE FOR MYSELF WHEN I
TURNED -- FORTY ANY PERSONAL
TASTE A STATEMENT THAT I
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN EVEN AFTER
I ENTERED THE PUBLIC.
DOMAIN AS A CANDIDATE FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE AGAIN AS I SAY I I YOU'D
BE SURPRISED AT THE NUMBER OF
CALLS AND LETTERS I RECEIVED
FROM PARENTS EVEN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
TEASED AND TAUNTED ABOUT --
THEIR CHOICE TO WEAR THEIR HAIR
IN ITS NATURAL KNOCKED NATURAL
FORM.
I THINK THIS BILL WHICH WILL --
SET A PRESIDENT AND PRESIDENT
NATIONWIDE IS CERTAINLY TIMELY
AND INCREASING ANOTHER-OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO EDUCATE
EACH OTHER ABOUT CULTURAL --
CHOICES THAT WE ALL MAKE I'M
PROUD TO WEAR MY LOCKS -- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
SOME PEOPLE MAY ASSUME WELL YOU
KNOW IF YOU HAVE TO MAKE SOME
SMALL ALTERATION TO GET A JOB
WHY WOULDN'T YOU -- TO LOCK WHEN
THIS HAIR IS A TIMELY PROCESS IT
IS A PERMANENT PROCESS -- TO NO
LONGER HAVE LOCKS ALL HAVE TO
CUT THEM OFF AND SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE ARE
EDUCATED.
BASED ON THE FACTS AND WE
CERTAINLY HOPE ARE IN A POSITION --
AS A SOCIETY TO FULLY EMBRACE
THE COMPLEXITIES AND DIVERSITIES
OF ALL PEOPLE WHO CONSTITUTE OF
THE WORKPLACE AND WOULD ACCEPT
MY PERSONAL CHOICE OF HOW TO
WEAR MY HERE -- AND MY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
CONSTITUTES PROFESSIONAL MISSILE
IN THE WORKPLACE AS THE STANDARD
THAT SHOULD BE MET AND SO WITH
THAT WE ASK FOR YOU TO SUPPORT
SB.
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
JACKSON HI JACKSON I BORDERS
[inaudible]
ALAN.
ALLEN I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE MONNING.
MONNING ICE STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
AMERICA I WAY CASKEY.
BY THE VOTE COUNT IS. SIX TWO
ZERO WE WILL CALL THE ROLL OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
I'M RECALLING WHEN I WAS MUCH
YOUNGER I WAS SITTING IN A CHAIR
IN A YEAR.
A BEAUTY SALON GETTING MY HAIR
AFTER ROAD WHILE AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN WAS SITTING IN
THE CHAIR RIGHT NEXT TO THE
OTHER.
RIGHT.
BUT YOU'RE GETTING A PERMIT SHE
WAS GET UNIVERSAL ARE YOU GO.
SO IT'S HARD BEING A WOMAN.
BUT I DID FEEL EMPOWERED BY THAT
THE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU
.
ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT ITEM IS --
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR HILL -- I'D
LIKE TO INDICATE THAT -- WE
RECEIVE NO TIMELY OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE AND LIKE THE
WITNESSES TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTE TEACHER IF YOU COULD.
AND WITH THAT IF I COULD GET
EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION HERE.
WE GET A LITTLE QUIET IN THE
ROOM.
GIVE YOU JUST A MOMENT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR HILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I I
COULD ONLY HOPE FOR A THE
OPPORTUNITY -- AT SOME POINT --
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
AND COLLEAGUES SB.
TWO TWENTY THREE WILL HELP
STUDENTS WITH SEVERE MEDICAL
DISABILITIES ATTEND SCHOOL OFTEN
THE ONLY MEDICATION THE WORK FOR
SOME OF THE STUDENTS IS MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN GUARDIAN TO COME ON
CAMPUS TODAY IT MINISTER OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS. TO THEM IN NON
SMOKING AND NON VAPING FORMS
MANY OF THE STUDENTS NEED TO
TAKE IT THOSE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS AT REGULAR INTERVALS
WHICH WILL OFTEN.
OCCURS DURING SCHOOL HOURS
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW ANY
FORM OF CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS.
THESE STUDENTS MUST BE PICKED UP
BY THEIR PARENTS SIGNED OUT AND
TAKEN OFF CAMPUS IN ORDER TO
TAKE THOSE THEIR MEDICATIONS AND
THE LAW REQUIRES ONE THOUSAND
FEET FROM THE CAMPUS.
THIS IS VERY DISRUPTIVE TO THEIR
LEARNING.
SB TWO TWENTY THREE WILL ALLOW
THE GOVERNING BOARD OF A K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION OR
CHARTER SCHOOL TO CHOOSE WHETHER
TO ADOPT THIS POLICY IT IS NOT A
STATE MANDATE.
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES AT OPT IN
CAN OPT OUT FOR ANY REASON
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PUT AT RISK AS A RESULT OF THIS
POLICY.
SB TWO TWENTY THREE REQUIRES THE
STUDENT TO BE A QUALIFIED
MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENT WITH A
DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION.
TYPICALLY THE MEDICINE IS
ADMINISTERED AS OIL CAPSULES
INSURERS LIQUIDS OR TOPICAL
CREAMS.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT A
PARENT MUST NOT DISRUPT THE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT AND MUST
TAKE ALL CANNABIS FROM SCHOOL.
FROM SCHOOL GROUNDS AFTER
ADMINISTRATION EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO LEGALLY
ADMINISTER ANY PHARMACEUTICAL
DRUG INCLUDING OPIATES.
THAT A CHILD HAS BEEN PRESCRIBED.
BUT THERE ARE MEDICAL CONDITIONS
PHARMACEUTICALS CAN'T FIX AND AS
WE KNOW THEY OFTEN HAVE
DEBILITATING SIDE EFFECTS.
MEDICAL CANNABIS HELPS FILL SOME
OF THESE GAPS IN LESSEN THE
THESE CHALLENGING SIDE EFFECTS.
PAIRS ACROSS THE NATION HAVE
ACCESS TREATING THEIR CHILDREN
WITH MEDICAL CANNABIS WHEN NO
PHARMACEUTICAL WOULD WORK
WASHINGTON COLORADO FLORIDA
MAINE AND NEW JERSEY HAVE ALL
PASSED.
LEGISLATION ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
USE MEDICAL CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
MUCH OF THE TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR IN
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KRENA
MCCAIN I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
JUDGES ACT SB.
TWO TO THREE MY SAN GIOVANNI JOE
JOE HE MENACE HAS USE CANNABIS
INTO INSURANCE CBT AND TEACH THE
FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
SINCE THE AGE OF THREE MONTHS
OLD HE HAS BEEN PLAGUED WITH
EPILEPSY IN TWENTY THIRTEEN HE
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH LENNIX
BECAUSE SO SYNDROME.
THIS IS A VERY RARE AND HARD TO
CONTROL EPILEPSY.
JO JO WAS MEDICATED WITH HIGH
DOSES OF PHARMACEUTICALS AND
ALSO FITTED WITH A DEVICE CALLED
THE VAGUS NERVE STIMULATOR ALL
WITH NO SUCCESS.
I WAS WATCHING MY SENDAI RIGHT
BEFORE MY EYES I KNEW THERE HAD
TO BE A BETTER WAY.
I BEGAN RESEARCHING CANNABIS AND
THE EFFECTS.
OF IT TO TREAT EPILEPSY AND
CHOSE TO TRY IT AS OUR LAST
RESORT.
WE HAD TO GET A WRITTEN APPROVAL
FROM OUR NEUROLOGISTS PRIOR TO
SEEKING A MEDICAL MARIJUANA
RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAD TO FIND A DOCTOR THAT
TREATED MINERS BECAUSE NOT ALL
DO.
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTEEN WAS THE
FIRST TIME WE TRIED CANNABIS
SENATE SEEM VERY HOPEFUL DAY BY
DAY I SEEN HIM EMERGE FROM IS
MEDICATED STATE AND START
ENGAGING AGAIN.
FEATURES WERE DECREASED
IMMEDIATELY.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL DUE TO JO JO
NEEDING A DOSE AT SCHOOL TWELVE
PM DAILY.
I FEEL CANNABIS SHOULD BE
TREATED AS EVERY OTHER
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ON CAMPUS.
IT IS NOT FAIR THAT THIS
MEDICINE AND SAVE MY SON'S LIFE
AND NOT BE GIVEN THE SAME
TREATMENT AND ABILITY.
AS OTHER PHARMACEUTICALS ON
CAMPUS I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
BILL BECOMING LAW.
MY SON'S LIFE AND SO MANY OTHERS
DEPEND ON IT.
IN FIVE THOUSAND YEARS NO ONE
HAS DIED FROM CANNABIS USE IT IS
THE ONLY MEDICINE.
THAT CAN TREAT SO MANY DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS ON SUCH A WIDE SPECTRUM
FROM APPLE APPS THE TO ARTHRITIS
THE CANCER TO PARKINSON'S.
IT ALSO HAS THE ABILITY TO
REGENERATE BRAIN CELLS THIS I
HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND.
I ASK YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART TO GIVE A YES VOTE TODAY
AND BE THE VOICE MY SON AND SO
MANY OTHERS NEED.
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY IS
MARCH TWENTY SIXTH IT'S EPILEPSY
AWARENESS DAY.
AND IT'S AMAZING TO BE HERE IN
FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE. TO GET
THIS PASSED TODAY.
AND I WANT TO PUT ALL CONCERNS
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS -- ABOUT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO OBTAIN.
ONE AND THE USE OF CANNABIS ON
CAMPUS BEING PUT IN THE WRONG
HANDS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I THINK WE ARE I RECALL YOU WERE
HERE LAST YEAR'S YES THANK YOU
IT WAS YOUR TENACITY.
SHARE YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS TWO MINUTES IF YOU COULD
LEAVE IT -- KEEP IT AT THAT
GREAT YES A GOOD MOM GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS AND HAPPY AT
APPLE OF SEE WHERE TO STAY.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER COOLIDGE I
WAS ALSO HERE LAST YEAR TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF MY SON ZACHARY -- I
AM HIS MOM AND I'M ALSO IN
INTENSIVE CARE NURSE AND A
SELFIE HOSPITAL LEVEL TWO TRAUMA
CENTER -- I SPOKE BEFORE YOU
LAST YEAR ABOUT ZACHARY -- HIS
SEIZURES HAD PROGRESSED TO THE
POINT WHERE HE WAS NO LONGER
ABLE TO SET UP ON HISOWN.
WE WERE GIVEN HOSPICE PAPERWORK
AND SENT HOME AFTER ALL
TREATMENT HAD BEEN EXHAUSTED.
A MY HUSBAND PROPOSED TRYING
CANNABIS AND TO SAY I WAS
AGAINST IT WOULD BE AN
UNDERSTATEMENT -- HOWEVER WITH
HOSTAGE PAPERWORK IN HAND I WAS
WILLING TO GIVE IT A TRY -- WE
ATTEMPTED TO CALL OVER TWENTY
DOCTORS IN THE GREATER BAY AREA
AND VISIT A HANDFUL.
ARE ALL THE SAME TOLD ALL OF
THEM TOLD US THE SAME THING
NOBODY WOULD WRITE A
RECOMMENDATION FOR A FIFTEEN
MONTH OLD CHILD.
AFTER A MONTH OF EXHAUSTIVE
SEARCHING OUR PEDIATRIC
NEUROLOGIST AGREED TO SIGN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH FORM.
NINE ZERO FOUR FOUR STATING THAT
DOCKERY'S CONDITION WAS
APPROPRIATE TO USE CANNABIS.
IT WAS AND ALWAYS WILL BE
ESSENTIAL DOCKERY CARE TEAM BE
ON BOARD WITH THIS TREATMENT
OPTION.
WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN OPEN AND
HONEST WITH HIS PROVIDERS IN HOW
WE ARE T<c.cyan> TREATING.</c>
AND WHEN WE HAD TO CHANGE
INSURANCE TWO YEARS AGO WE HAD
TO FIND A WHOLE NEW CARE TEAM.
OR REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
DOCUMENTATION REGARDING HIS
CONDITION AND NEED FOR CANNABIS
USE.
BECAUSE OF THE STIPULATIONS
PLACED ON CHILDREN NOW ZACHARY
HAS TO LOSE THIRTY MINUTES EVERY
DAY TO GET HIS MEDICATIONS.
SO FAR THIS YEAR HE HAS LOST
THREE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MINUTES OF EDUCATIONAL
TIME TO RECEIVE HIS MEDICATIONS.
THAT'S 10% OF HIS LEARNING TIME
IN THE CLASSROOM.
ON BEHALF OF THAT GREEN ALL
CHILDREN WHO REQUIRE CANNABIS TO
CONTROL SEIZURES AND OTHER
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE TO LOT OF TIME ON
THE SCHOOL TO GET CANNABIS AND
MOST OF THIS IS DONE IN SOME
KIND OF OF LIQUID FORM OR HARD
TO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO EVEN.
BE DOING THIS BUT ANYWAY ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IF YOU TO STEP FORWARD.
ERICA HOFFMAN I'M HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND ON BEHALF OF THE
NEED FOR ALL STUDENTS. TO HAVE A
CAN CAN US AND UNINTERRUPTED
SCHOOL DAY ESPECIALLY STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS WE WOULD
STRONGLY OR DRIVE A THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
RATE THE SCHOOL BOARD SERVICE
SUPPORT ON THIS THANK YOU MAR
INTERNET WITH THE NET ACCOUNT IS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE THE
LARGEST MARKET.
IN THE ANY STATE SIDE OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES -- WET
THANK TO SENATOR AS WE HAVE A
GREAT NUMBER A GOOD NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS THAT ARE COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR FOR MEDICAL
REASONS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
[inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FRANCO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THE LARGEST
A TRADE ASSOCIATION THE STATE
REPRESENTED THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WILL KEVIN LINDSAY --
WOULD SERVICES SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ABOVE REALLY -- SUPPORTERS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MATT HI CALIFORNIA CIVIL
LIBERTIES ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DON'T HAVE ANY NOTED.
OUR WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I REMEMBER THIS BILL
LAST YEAR.
CANNABIS IS NOW LEGAL IN THE
UNITED IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WERE
LEGAL EVERYWHERE MIGHT MAKE IT A
LITTLE EASIER TO BE DEALING WITH
THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
IT BUT CERTAINLY [inaudible]
OF THE FACT THAT IT'S NOW LEGAL
IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS NOT THE
BOOGIE MAN.
WHICH IS KIND OF SHOCKING THAT
WE LOOK AT IT IN THAT WAY
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR YOUNGSTERS
FOR WHOM THIS HAS BEEN.
OF ALMOST A MIRACLE DRUG IT
SOUNDS LIKE SO -- I JUST HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE DID
HEAR THIS THOROUGHLY LAST YEAR --
AND THEN I'LL ASK A CENTER
MONNING TO GO GO FOR WITH HIS
QUESTIONS -- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE FDA
APPROVED A DRUG DERIVED FROM
CANNABIS FOR THE TREATMENT OF TO
SEVERE FORMS OF EPILEPSY AFTER
LAST YEAR'S BILL PASSED OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND I'M WONDERING.
IF THAT MEDICATION IS NOW
AVAILABLE TO CHILDREN.
IS IT IS IT IS IT IS IT'S IN A
SYNTHETIC FORM IT'S NOT.
OF THE LAND LIKE THE TEACHERS
THAT WE PROVIDE OUR CHILDREN
WITH -- WITH SYNTHETIC FORM COME
SIDE EFFECTS.
AND THEY I'LL YOU KNOW THE RISK
IS JUST TOO HIGH.
I BELIEVE MY PERSONAL OPINION I
WOULD NOT USE THT MEDICINE FOR
MY CHILD.
ALL RIGHT AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE AGAIN.
THE C. B. D. IN THE OILS AND THE
CREAMS ARE JUST NOT.
GOING TO HURT ANYBODY.
THEY JUST DON'T PENALIZE YOU
CAN'T YOU DON'T INHALE IT SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE DOWN WIND AND
WORRY ABOUT GETTING A HI THIS IS
IT'S LIKE.
THE BILL INCLUDING ON NEOSPORIN
HER SOMETHING I JUST -- IT IT IT
IS KIND OF A SHOCKING BUT LAST
QUESTION I HAVE IS -- WHAT OTHER
ILLNESSES OR OR ARE YOU AWARE OF
THAT -- DOCTORS RECOMMENDED A
CHILDREN BE TREATED WITH MEDICAL
CANNABIS ARE THERE OTHERS A
COULD YOU KIND OF GIVE US AN
IDEA BECAUSE WE'RE NOT JUST
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN WITH
EPILEPSY IN SCHOOL THOSE OF
MEDICATION IT'S PROBABLY VERY
HELPFUL.
IN OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES SO IF YOU
COULD ENLIGHTEN US A LITTLE BIT
ON THAT THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED.
UP WILL LIKE CANCER DEFINITELY
THE SIDE EFFECTS AND THE
DEBILITATING THINGS THAT IT
BRINGS -- MIGRAINES ARTHRITIS
THERE'S LOTS OF DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS CROHN'S DISEASE -- IT
IS AN ANTI INFLAMMATORY TYPE OF
MEDICATION.
SO ANYTHING LIKE MS THAT'S
ANOTHER -- DEBILITATING DISEASE
THAT CVD HAS PROVEN TO PROVIDE
SUCH EXTREME BENEFITS FOR AND BE
ABLE TO HAVE MINIMAL
PHARMACEUTICAL.
BECAUSE THAT SIDE FEEL THAT WHEN
YOU BRING IN SUCH LARGE DOSES OF
PHARMACEUTICALS.
YOU GET TEN OTHER PROBLEMS ALL
THE SIDE EFFECTS.
SO -- THAT'S THE GREAT PART
ABOUT CVD IN THC IS THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT ACCOMPANYING THE
MEDICATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTER MONNING.
YOU MADAM CHAIR IN WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BACK IN THE WITNESSES FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND INTERESTINGLY AS
YOU POINTED OUT ON NATIONAL
EPILEPSY YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
THE ANSWER T THIS BUT I A KIND
OF ALONG THE LINES OF THE CHAIR
ASKING SOME OF THE OTHER
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE.
BEEN PROVEN TO BENEFIT.
DO WE HAVE AN IDEA OF ESTIMATE
IN CALIFORNIA HOW MANY STUDENTS
HOW MANY FAMILIES.
ARE BEING.
ADVERSELY IMPACTED RIGHT NOW IN
OTHER WORDS HAVING TO LEAVE THE
SCHOOL GROUNDS -- WELL IN MY A
PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE A LOT OF
PARENTS ARE DOES SING AROUND
SCHOOL SO THEY'RE NOT EVEN GOING
THE CAMPUS AND PULLING THEIR
CHILDREN NOW.
AND WHAT THAT DOES IS IT IT'S A
DELAYED RESPONSE TO THE
MEDICATION YOU'RE NOT GETTING
FULL BENEFITS BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
ON THE PROPER REGIMENT.
SO PARENTS ARE CHOOSING TO SEE
DOES THEIR CHILDREN BEFORE THEY
GO TO SCHOOL AND THEN AS SOON AS
THEY GET HOME.
WHICH COULD BE SIXTY EIGHT TO
pDOSING THEM AGAIN AND WHEN
YOU'RE DOING THAT YOU'RE CHASING
YOU'RE NOT.
RATING THE MEDICAL SUBSTANCE
THAT YOU NEED TO WITH WITH STAND
IN YOUR BODY.
IT DEPLETES MATTER SING THAT'S
TRUE WITH.
SO CALLED REGULAR FIRM SETTING
VIA EXACTLY -- IT BUT ANY IDEA
OF HOW MANY FAMILIES WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL I KNOW A
LOT OF FAMILIES THAT I'M HERE
REPRESENTING AND FIGHTING FOR
TODAY.
THAT ARE IN MY PEDIATRIC
CANNABIS GROUPS AND EPILEPSY
GROUPS.
NO WELL I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT
NUMBER.
THE MONEY I'D I DON'T KNOW AND
AND WE SHOULD LIKE TO ANSWER BUT
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A CLEAR
NUMBER BECAUSE MOST PARENTS ARE.
KIND OF RELUCTANT TO TO BRING
THAT TO SCHOOL OR TO THANK ABOUT
THIS -- BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THAT ARE AROUND.
AND AS I UNDERSTAND.
SENATOR YOUR BILL WOULD MAKE
THIS A VOLUNTARY BY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT IS IT'S IT'S
VOLUNTARY BY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
IT'S AN OPT IN PROGRAM FOUR OF
THE FIVE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
PASSED THIS HAVE IT MADE IT MADE
IT MANDATORY IN THE STATE SO
IT'S AT AN OPT OUT.
BRIAN AND FOR IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP BUT I YES JUST FOR WHATEVER
REASONS IF THERE'S A PATCHWORK
SOME FAMILIES -- WOULDN'T BE
SERVED BY.
BY THIS GREATER ACTIVITY -- BUT
AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING
IT FORWARD I'D BE GLAD TO MOVE
THE BILL THE APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO A FEW
MORE QUESTIONS SENATOR ALLEN
FALL BY SENATOR STERN.
BY WHEN IT FIRST THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR FOR WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION MEMBER THIS BILL
CAME TO EDUCATION COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR AND AND YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE WERE THERE ANY OTHER SOME
FEDERALISM IN THERE SOME ISSUES
WHERE THE SCHOOL I'M DISTRICTS
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT -- THIS IS
STILL ILLEGAL AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL IN THERE SOME CHALLENGES
THERE -- BUT THIS DOES REQUIRE
THAT THE SCHOOL BOARD HAS THAT
KIND OF EXAMINE THIS DISCUSS IN
PUBLIC AND THERE CAN BE AN OPEN
MEETING.
AND AND DECISION THAT'S MADE
LOCALLY AND ITS LOCAL
ACCOUNTABLE WHAT I IT WAS
UNCLEAR ABOUT I WAS READING --
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO SO THAT IT
SAYS THAT THE GOVERNOR OF COURSE
WE ALL KNOW THE GOVERNOR VETOED.
THE BILL IN A PRESIDENTE CALLED
WHAT YOU PROPOSED.
AND HE SAYS.
THIS BILL IS OVERLY BROAD AS IT
APPLIES TO ALL STUDENTS INSTEAD
OF LIMITED CASES WHERE DOCTOR
RECOMMENDS MEDICAL MARIJUANA FOR
STUDENT ORDER. TO PREVENT.
OR REDUCE THE SIDE EFFECTS OF A
SEIZURE -- BUT IT IS NOT ALL
STUDENTS ARE YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
CHILD YOU HAVE TO HAVE A MEDICAL
CANNABIS RECOMMENDATION ON FILE.
FOR IT TO BE.
EVEN BY THE DIRECTION -- INTO A
THINK WHAT HE WAS REFERRING TO
IS IT APPLIES TO ALL STUDENTS
THAT HAVE MEDICAL
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM PHYSICIANS
SO IT WOULD BE.
EXPANDING THE USE I I I BELIEVE
HE WAS MORE INTERESTED IN
FOCUSING ON EPILEPSY HAS A
PARTICULAR AILMENT BUT WHAT HE
WAS DOING IN THAT.
YOU KNOW MESSAGES HE'S ACTUALLY
IS STATING SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE IMPOSSIBLE TO ENFORCE BECAUSE
IF YOU.
ARE ONLY GETTING MEDICAL
CANNABIS IN THE SCHOOL THAN YOU
HAVE.
IDENTIFIED A PARTICULAR AILMENT
WTH THAT PARTICULAR STUDENT AS
HAVING THAT EPILEPSY WHICH IS IN
VIOLATION OF HIP -- IF THAT
BECOMES A PART OF THE THE RECORD
OR THE SCHOOL IS USING THAT
INFORMATION SO I THINK HAT WAS
KIND OF A WRONG DIRECTION. TO TO
BE GOING AND NOT PARTICULARLY A
LEGAL ONE AT THAT.
WITH THAT IT THAT HAS BEEN THAT
THE PRIVACY ISSUES THE HIP
ISSUES ARE STILL SOMETHING I
KNOW THAT WE WORKED ON LAST YEAR
ON THIS AND AGAIN -- INTO
ASTONISHING TO ME THAT WE TALK
TALK TALK ABOUT THIS IS SOME.
KIND OF ARCANE MEDICAL.
CREATION WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
A PRODUCT THAT I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE USE I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE USES FOR ARTHRITIS.
I HAVE YET TO SEE THEM.
RUN AROUND ON THE CEILINGS AND
BE KIND OF CRAZY.
HI THAT'S A DIFFERENT A VERY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE I SUSPECT
BUT CERTAINLY THE THE THE
MEDICAL PART OF THIS IS VERY
DIFFERENT AND SO -- I THINK THAT
THEY'RE APPLES AND ORANGES BUT
WE BUT THIS IS AN ATTEMPT NOW
AND WORKING WITH THE SCHOOLS AND
AGAIN I'M VERY PLEASED TO SEE
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE.
REALLY WILLING TO COME.
A STEP UP ON THIS THIS IS NOT
THIS IS NOT A YOU KNOW A LIFE
THREATENING SITUATION THIS IS
ACTUALLY LIFESAVING AND AND THE
WAY WE DEALT WITH CANNABIS
[inaudible]
OF THE PAST MANY YEARS HAS JUST
BEEN SO WRONG HEADED CERTAINLY
CANNABIS OF THIS NATURE SO AND
C. B. D. -- SO.
I THINK AGAIN THERE ARE THE
MEDICAL ISSUES SOCIAL GET I
THINK THEY CAN GET WORKED OUT AS
WE GO FORWARD BUT THIS FOCUS
RIGHT HERE IS ON JUST MAKING IT
AVAILABLE.
SO CHILDREN DON'T HAVE TO LOSE
ALL THESE HOURS OF SCHOOL IF
THEY IF THIS IS YOU KNOW IF THIS
CANNABIS RECIBE DEAR WHATEVER
THAT.
THE PRODUCT IS IS ABLE TO HELP
THESE CHILDREN LEAD NORMAL LIVES.
US SENATOR STERN.
ALL RIGHT THIS GUEST CENTER
BORDERS.
WHEN I WAS IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
IF I IF I WOULD IF I WAS SICK --
MY MY MOTHER WOULD BRING.
THE ANTIBIOTICS TO SCHOOL AND
THE NURSE -- WOULD FOLLOW THE
THE REGIMEN AND I'D BE CALLED IN.
AND WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
SCHOOL NURSE -- WHY ISN'T THAT
AN OPTION IN SOMETHING WITH
SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
IT'S A OR IS THAT UNDER THE
GUARDIAN IS TO GIVE THAT UNDER
GUARDIAN.
NO IT WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED UNDER
ANY CIRCUMSTANCE HERE MAINLY THE
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND SCHOOL
FACULTY WE'RE VERY CONCERNED.
THAT THEY WOULD BE
ADMINISTRATION WHAT WOULD BE A
CAN CONSIDERED A FEDERALLY --
ILLEGAL PRODUCT AND THAT ALSO
COULD CALL INTO QUESTION PERHAPS
THE THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT COME
TO THOSE SCHOOLS IF THERE WERE
THAT WERE EVER QUESTION SO.
THE EVEN THOUGH THEY DO THAT
WITH OPIOID TO DO WITH
ANTIBIOTICS AND THEY ADMINISTER
THEM TO THE STUDENTS -- BECAUSE
OF THE THE SENSITIVE NATURE OF
OF CANNABIS -- THE WERE
RELUCTANT AND ALSO I BELIEVE
BECAUSE THERE ARE EVEN THOUGH
THIS IS AS THE C. B. D. IS THE
C. B. D. PART.
THERE IS ALWAYS A TRACE AMOUNT A
GENERALLY OF THC WITHIN THAT
PRODUCT.
NOT ENOUGH TO CREATE THE
PSYCHOACTIVE OF FACT BUT THERE
IS SOME WE IN THAT AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THE THE SCHOOLS WANTED
TO HAVE THAT.
ON THEIR CAMPUS UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE EVEN THOUGH THE
OPIOIDS OF EVERY LEVEL ARE THERE
BUT IT'S I THINK THERE'S A
SENSITIVITY THERE AND WE WANTED
TO RESPECT THAT.
OUR AND LAST QUESTION.
THIS IS WHERE I HAVE A TOUGH
TIME.
AND IT'S NOT.
ANYTHING THAT CAN BE RESOLVED
TODAY IS THE IDEA OF A DOCTOR'S
RECOMMENDATION VERSES A
PRESCRIPTION -- I HAVE A TOUGH
TIME WITH THAT IF IF IT'S IF FOR
MAKING LEAPS AND BOUNDS AS WE
ARE AS A STATE IN THIS DIRECTION.
DESPITE THE THE FEDERAL --
PLEASE THE MIME SO OFFBEAT
BEFORE YOU CAN EVEN MOVE ON TO A
MEDICAL MARIJUANA DOCTOR WHO
TREATS MINORS YOU HAVE TO GET.
THE CONSENT OF YOUR PEDIATRICIAN
OR NEUROLOGISTS OR THE COVERING
DOCTOR.
PHIL -- NOT TO SAY THAT THEY
CAN'T WRITE THE RECOMMENDATION
AS WELL SO THE RECOMMENDATION IS
THE PRESCRIPTION.
SO YOU YOU CAN'T GET A
PRESCRIPTION FOR CANNABIS
JOCASTA YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND
LET ALONE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL --
ANYONE.
CAN GET A RECOMMENDATION.
NOT WHEN IT COMES TO MINORS
EXACTLY NOW WHEN IT COMES TO
MINORS SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN OF THE OPINION THAT
BEFORE MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION
THEN.
THE DOCTOR SHOULD BE IN A
POSITION OF HAVING TO STAND
BEHIND.
THEIR THEIR ADDRESS MEN ON OR
DIAGNOSIS OF A GIVEN ISSUE AND
FOLLOW THROUGH ONE AS OPPOSED TO
RECOMMENDATION THAT'S A SIDE
ISSUE.
BUT IT IS THE PHYSICIAN IT IS A
MEDICAL DOCTOR THAT MAKES THE
RECOMMENDATION.
YES -- ONE HUNDRED OUT OF ONE
HUNDRED REQUESTED MY NECK OF THE
WOODS NO ONE HAS EVER BEEN
DENIED -- RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THEN
WE SHOULD BE HAVING TO THE
CANNOT.
CHATTER IF YOU'RE USING TINCTURE
OF CVD OR SOMETHING IT IS.
THERE IS NO -- PSYCHEDELIC
BENEFIT YEAH THAT THIS IS JUST
LIKE PUTTING A HAND CREAM ON
YOUR HANDS OR TAKING USING A
LITTLE SOMETHING FOR OF FRANKLY
HOW ANTIQUATED.
AND HOW THE THE NEANDERTHAL WE
ARE WHEN IT COMES.
TO DEALING WITH THE SUBSTANCE
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY
THEORETICALLY A DOCTOR SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PRESCRIBE IT RATHER THAN
RECOMMENDED BUT UNTIL WE GET
SOME.
THE INSIDE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE'RE KIND OF JUST TO
RETURNING OURSELVES INTO A
PRETZEL TO MAKE IT AVAILABLE AS
AS IT SHOULD BE FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT.
BUT BUT APPRECIATE THAT THE
OTHER COMMON IF I MIGHT.
IS ARE AS FAR AS SCHOOL NURSES
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE A LOT OF
SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE NURSES SO.
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM WHEN
YOU AND I WERE IN SCHOOL ARM I
SHOULD SAY I WAS IN SCHOOL LONG
BEFORE YOU.
EVERY SCHOOL DID HAVE A NURSE.
BUT THEY DON'T TODAY SENATOR
STERN -- I WAS GONNA SAY
ANYTHING BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR
FOR THE RECORD THIS IS NOT ONLY
C. B. D. THIS IS ALSO THE
INGESTION OF THC THAT WOULD BE
ALLOWED HERE SO IT'S NOT JUST --
TOPICAL TINCTURES OUR BOMBS YOU
ACTUALLY THERE STILL IS THE
PSYCHOTROPIC EFFECTS IN THE THC
EVEN IF MINOR OR SOME SMALL NOW
WE KNOW IT'S USEFUL AS AN
ACTIVATION AGENT.
WHEN CMBINED WITH THE C. B. D.
IS WHICH IS WHY THEY LEAVE IT IN
THERE BT?
THERE STILL IS IN INJECT SOME
SOME AMOUNT OF TEACH SEATED
HELLO JOE OR YOUR SON.
IN JAIL RIGHT.
AND SO SO ON THAT THE YOU
MENTION THE PUBLIC HEALTH FORM
NINETY FORTY FOUR I BELIEVE IS
WHAT IT IS.
I WOULD ACT THIS WAY -- LOW BLOW
THERE'S A PROTOCOL HELLO SURE
HANDED TO THE SERGEANTS SERGEANT.
AND SO THE ANSWER TO THIS IS
WHAT PRECEDES THE MEDICAL
RECOMMENDATION THIS IS THE
TRIGGER.
TO OR IS THIS IS THE
DOCUMENTATION OF THE
RECOMMENDATION.
AT THE DOCUMENTATION OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO DISASTROUS
PEDIATRIC NEUROLOGIST -- AT
KAISER FIND THAT THEY HAVE TO
PUT A PHONE NUMBER ON THERE AND
EVERYTHING AND THEN I CAN MAIL
THAT INTO THE STATE TO GET HIM A
CANNABIS CARD.
THAT WE COULD THEN GO TO
DISPENSARIES. TO GET MEDICATION
FOR HIM BUT I WENT TO LIKE.
MULTIPLE DOCTORS WE CALLED
TWENTY WE WENT TO MULTIPLE
DOCTORS NOBODY WOULD SIGN THAT
FORM FOR US.
BECAUSE ACREE WAS SIXTEEN MONTHS
OLD FIFTEEN MONTHS OLD AT THE
TIME SO.
THE PEDIATRIC NEUROLOGIST WE
RECEIVE THE TIME SIGN THAT FORM
IN OUR CURRENT PEDIATRIC
NEUROLOGIST THAT WE SWITCH TO
SIGN THAT FORM.
SO THEY CAN BE ON CAMPUS.
FOR DOCUMENTATION PURPOSES AT
HIS SCHOOL.
ALONG WITH CONSENT OF THAT
DOCTORS SAYING THIS CHILD OR
YOUNG ADULT NEEDS THIS TYPE OF
MEDICATION -- THE OTHER THING
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS NOW
THAT -- CANNABIS IS
RECREATIONALLY LEGAL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- THERE'S NOT SO
MANY A MEDICAL MARIJUANA DOCTORS
HANDING OUT RECOMMENDATIONS
ANYMORE BECAUSE IT'S LEGAL.
SO THERE.
IT LEVY IT DOES LEAVE THE FUEL --
MEDICAL MARIJUANA DOCTORS THAT
ARE TREATING AND A VERY SMALLER
AMOUNT THAT TREAT MINOR.
SO YOU -- THE DID YOU HAVE
ANOTHER YEAH JUST JUST THIS
PROFESSION IS IT IS THERE ANY
WAY TO TO THREAD THE NEEDLE HERE
WHERE BECAUSE I SEE IT'S IT AND
IT'S A RELATIVELY EXPANSIVE LIST
WHICH IS MAYBE WHERE THE LAST
GOVERNOR'S CONCERN CAME IN
AROUND NAUSEA.
OR ANY OTHER CHRONIC MEDICAL
SYMPTOM THAT SUBSTANTIAL LIMITS
THE PERSON'S ABILITY CONDUCT
MAJOR LIFE ACTIVITIES OR CHRONIC
PAIN SO STARTED TO DEAL WITH
THESE [inaudible]
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUES
WITHOUT.
GETTING INTO THE HIPAA VIOLATION
BUT IS THERE IS THERE ANY WAY TO
SORT OF THREAD THAT NEEDLE TO
FIND A WAY.
TO SORT A NARROWLY ADDRESS THE
YOUNG PEOPLE HERE BUT NOT SORT
OF HAVE THAT BACK DOOR IF THERE
WAS ABUSING THE SYSTEM AT ALL
FOR IN TERMS OF YOU NAUSEA
RELATED OR THINGS THAT SORT OF
MIGHT BE.
NOT TO SEE YOU KNOW PARENTS ARE
GOING TO GO OUT OF THEIR WAY
PROBABLY TOO YOU KNOW FALSE GET
OF SOME FALSE PRESCRIPTION FOR
OF YOU KNOW.
FAKE NAUSEA OR WHATEVER BUT IS
THERE SOME WAITED TO TO THE
THREAD THAT NEED WITHOUT
VIOLATING SOME OF THE HIT HIP A
CONCERN I DON'T KNOW REYES YOU
WOULD DO THAT I DON'T I DON'T.
KNOW HOW YOU COULD MAKE THAT
JUDGMENT I MEAN THAT'S WHY WE
INTEREST.
THOSE DECISIONS TO THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION. TO TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THIS IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE CHILD AND AS WE
HAVE THE NEUROLOGISTS TO ME THAT
NOT A MEDICAL BOTTOM AMID THIS
ANOTHER MARIJUANA DR.
BUT A REGULAR PEDIATRICIAN OR
NEUROLOGISTS TO PEDIATRIC
NEUROLOGIST WHO HAS TO MAKE THAT
DECISION THIS IS A COLLECTIVE.
THIS IS BASICALLY A TREATMENT
FOR A CONDITION THAT HAS BEEN
MEDICALLY IDENTIFIED SO -- AND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION SENATOR PER.
YEAH SENATOR BURGESS -- OF I HAD
A QUESTION ABOUT WHAT WAS IT
ABOUT EDIBLES.
IS SO NONE OF THESE ARE WHAT WE
WOULD CALL EDIBLES ARE THEY WILL
BUILD A TEAM SURE IT'S AN OIL
FOR MANY GOES IN YOUR MOUTH SO-TECHNICALLY YOU CAN CALL IT AN
EDIBLE BUT IT'S NOT A BAKED ITEM
OR COOKIE OR A GUN NEEDS.
ITS OIL IT LOOKS JUST LIKE OLIVE
OIL LIGHT AND GOES INTO THE
MOUTH AND IT'S INGESTED THAT WAY
AND TOP OF HOLES ARE EITHER IN A
CREAM OR LIKE A BOMB TYPE OF
AGENT -- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IT IS REVERSED AND IS JUST
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
WITH OUR MEDICINAL CANNABIS
WOULD BE MAY BE HELPFUL TO
ARTICULATE.
AND REFINED THAT DOWN CAUSE
MEDICINAL IS.
WHATEVER WE DEEM IT TO BE IN
SOME INSTANCES -- MY RESPONSE TO
YOU IT IN ORDER IT I KNOW ON THE
PAPER IT SEEMS CRIED LIKE HELD
ON HOLD. ONE QUESTION AT A TIME.
WHEN INSERTED OKAY?
YOUR QUESTION WAS STILL
OUTSTANDING WHICH WAS.
WHAT IS WE'VE NOW MOVED ON TO
ANOTHER QUESTION?
FEEL THE BROAD SPECTRUM ON THE
FORM IN ORDER TO EVEN PROCEED
FORWARD YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SEVERE ENOUGH CONDITION FOR THAT
ARE ALL EDGES OR THAT
PEDIATRICIAN TO SAY.
OKAY YOU NEED THIS YEAR JUST NOT
NAUSEOUS FOR THE DAY ARE HAVING
SOME GASTRIC ISSUES LIKE YOUR
NEED IS SO SEVERE AND OUR
PHARMACEUTICALS ARE ADDING TO
THE PROBLEM THEY'RE NOT HELPING
THE PROBLEM.
THEREFORE I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND RECOMMEND THIS FOR YOU TO GO
SEEK MEDICAL MARIJUANA DOCTOR
THAT TREATS MINERS AND GET THE
MEDICATION THAT YOU NEED.
AND THEN YOU CAN COME BACK AND
WE CAN WORK A DOSES OR THE
AMOUNT THAT YOU'RE TAKING AND
AND FOLLOW BECAUSE MY
PEDIATRICIAN AND RELIGIOUS
FOLLOW ME AS WELL.
IT'S NOT JUST THE MEDICAL
MARIJUANA DOCTOR THAT PRESCRIBED --
THE RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT IT'S A QUICK
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION DO WE GET
AN ANSWER SOME OF THESE ARE
TINCTURES ARGUABLY COULD SAY
THEY'RE EDIBLE BECAUSE IT'S A
TINCTURE THAT YOU PUT ON THE
MILD.
THESE ARE ALL PRESCRIBED ARE
THEY NOT YES THROUGH THIS
RECOMMENDATION WE CAN'T CALL IT
A PRESCRIPTION BECAUSE THE FEDS
HAVE WOKEN UP YET.
BUT IT IS STATE THEY ARE.
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS A MEDICINE.
IT JUST HAPPENS TO INCLUDE
CANNABIS THERE MIGHT BE A LITTLE
THC TO ACTIVATE IT.
NOTHING THAT WOULD GET YOU HIGH
BUT A MEDICAL OF THE TREATMENT
THAT ASSIST IN THE CARE OF THESE
ILLNESSES ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT.
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION I
BELIEVE.
AND OF THE MOTION IS.
DUEPASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
HEY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL JACKSON BY ACCIDENT I
FORGES.
ORDERS NO ALAN.
ALLEN I GOT A HERO.
CABALLERO AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE STERN.
STERN I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY. FOR THAT THE
TWO FIVE TO ONE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSION
AND PERSISTENCE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
I'D OUR LAST ITEM IS ITEM FIVE A
VERY PATIENT -- SENATOR DORADO
IS COMING -- I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME
A CENTER ON BURKE HASSLE LAST
ITEM -- TWO ITEMS LIVE SENATOR
DHIRAJ SHOWS SB TWO TWENTY FIVE
FILE ITEM. FIVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE -- AND THIS IS --
ITEM FIVE ON OUR LIST.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
THERE HAS BEEN NO TIMELY
OPPOSITION.
OF PRESENTED TO THIS MEASURE AND
WANT TO WELCOME YOU CENTER DRAWS
SO TO THE COMMITTEE I THINK THIS
IS YOUR FIRST BILL -- WELCOME
AND YOU MAY PROCEED REMINDER
THAT WITNESSES TO WITNESSES.
ON EACH SIDE TWO MINUTES EACH SO
CENTER DRAWS SO THE FLOORS
FINALLY YOURS AND IS THIS.
THIS IS A SON OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK AND ALL THE ISSUES
THAT YOU TAKE UP.
A I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON SB.
TWO TWO FIVE THIS IS A BILL THAT
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIANS.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
MAY SERVE ON CALIFORNIA'S AND
LOCALS STATE OF STATE AND LOCAL
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS -- SB TWO
TWO FIVE REMOVES A VERY OBSOLETE
CODE SECTION WRITTEN. TO EXCLUDE
IMMIGRANTS FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THE CIVIC LIFE IT WAS WRITTEN IN
THE EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES.
ALMOST A HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS
AGO SO AS B. TWO TWO FIVE
REMOVES AN OBSOLETE CODE SECTION.
WRITTEN -- TO EXCLUDE IMMIGRANTS --
IT IS NOT GOING TO CIRCUMVENT
FEDERAL AUTHORITY TO EMPLOY OR
NOT EMPLOYEE UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT EMPLOYMENT.
OUR INTENT IN SB TO DO FIVE IS
TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO SERVICE.
AN AUTHORIZED ALL AUTHORIZED ALL
QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE ON
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE -- STATE A
LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS AND
THAT'S BECAUSE WE WANT BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS THAT TRULY
REFLECT THE COMMUNITIES AND THE
STATE AS A WHOLE -- THEY BETTER
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE THERE ARE
NEIGHBORS ARE THE PARENTS OF THE
KIDS THAT GO TO SCHOOL WITH OUR
KIDS -- THE GO TO CHURCHES OR
SYNAGOGUES WHEREVER WE GO THEY
ARE OUR FRIENDS THEY ARE OUR
FAMILIES THEY HAVE MANY TALENTS
ON THAT WE SHOULD BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF ON OUR BOARDS AND
AND COMMISSIONS -- THEY HAVE
DIVERSE EXPERIENCES ACADEMIC OF
WHEN THEY HAVE ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS SCIENCES ARTS JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT AS A LEGAL MATTER.
THIS BILL WILL ALIGN THE STATE'S
DEFINITION OF CITIZEN WITH THE
DEFINITION FOUND IN THE
CITIZENSHIP CLAUSE OF THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT.
PUTTING AN END TO OLD LANGUAGE
MEANT TO DISCRIMINATE AT THAT
TIME AGAINST CHINESE IMMIGRANTS
SO WITH THAT.
MADAM CHAIR WITH THAT SAID I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE -- AND THE TWO
WITNESSES TODAY ARE OF THE ANA.
WHO IS WITH THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
CHRIS TO RESIGN CHISHOLM POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH ALSO WITH CHIRLA?
GOOD AFTERNOON TWO MINUTES EACH
PLEASE.
PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ADRIANA AND I'M A POT PROUD
DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANT PARENTS A
PROUD SISTER FOR US CITIZEN AND
A PROUD FIRST GENERATION
DOCUMENTED UC DAVIS ALUMNI.
WITH A BACHELORS OF SCIENCE IN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE AND
MANAGEMENT.
WHO HAS A PRIVILEGE TO BE IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY AND URGE TO
SUPPORT SB?
TWO TWENTY FIVE WITHIN ITS
BORDERS CALIFORNIA HOLD BOTH
DENSE URBAN AREAS AND INTENSE
INDUSTRIAL AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION HUGE STRETCH
STRETCHES OF DRY PRAIRIE.
AND WATER RICH MOUNTAINS.
POLICY DECISIONS AND THESE AREAS
HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE ONE NOT ONLY
GROUPS.
WHILE NOT THE ONLY GROUPS
AFFECTED BY FACT BY THESE
FACTORS ARE LESS ABLE TO RESIST
ENVIRONMENTAL HAZARDS BECAUSE OF
THEIR SYSTEMATIC ERASURE.
AND MARGINAL STATUS WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES AND OUR BUS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
WITHIN THE SOLDIER CENTRAL
VALLEY AND THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
TODAY THERE IS LITTLE
REPRESENTATION FOR SUCH A
VULNERABLE POPULATION WITHIN
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS ABOUT THE
INTERSECTION OF IMMIGRATION AND
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS LACK OF ATTENTION SPEAKS TO
THE IMPORTANCE OF SB. TWO TWENTY
FIVE TO ALLOW ALL CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS TO SERVE ON
STATE AND LOCAL BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS.
THEREFORE UNDERSTANDING POSITION
MALADY AN INTERSECTION MALADY
ALLOWANCES TO ACQUIRE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICES
EXPERIENCED BY AND DOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SERVE ON THE
COMMISSION LIKE THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT YOU WILL ALLOW ME
AND MY COMMUNITY OF TEN MILLION
TO SAVE ON THESE ARE BORN BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT NEXT WITNESS CHRIS FOR
SIGNS OF CHIRLA PRADA BE A
SPONSOR THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION JUST BRIEFLY
REMARKED THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL
MEASURE FOR IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION. TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE IS ABLE TO HAVE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE AND HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD -- PROPERLY AS A
MAKE DECISIONS ARE GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU
PLEASE STEP FOR WITH YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION.
BACK A KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF
OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANDRE RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND CALIFORNIA'S CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE WE DID NOTGET ANY WRITTEN
OPPOSITION IS ARE ANY OPPOSITION
HERE TODAY.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS OF
THEIR ANY QUESTIONS.
YOU HAVE QUESTIONS.
CENTER BORDERS.
THANK YOU A MESSAGES FOR A
CLARIFICATION.
SO I'M LOOKING AT SECTION
[inaudible] TEN TWENTY A OF THE
GRAY BACK BILL.
IT IS IDENTIFYING A PERSON.
IN THE CHANGE OF LANGUAGE IS
ELIGIBLE TO HOLD AN ELECTIVE
CIVIL OFFICE.
AND AN ELECTIVE CIVIL OFFICE IS
CAN BE HELD.
ELECTED OFFICE -- ARE THERE
LIMITATIONS ON THAT.
IT'S A SIMPLE OFFICE.
IF AT THE TIME.
OF THE PERSON IS EIGHTEEN YEARS
OF AGE.
AND A CITIZEN.
THE CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF THE
STATE OR BRING.
TO SO I GUESS MY MY QUESTION IS --
IF THIS.
UNDER THIS CHANGE WOULD AN
INDIVIDUAL BE ABLE TO LET'S SAY
RUN FOR JUDGE.
AND ENFORCE THE LAWS.
WOULD THAT BE AN ELIGIBLE.
PURSUIT OKAY.
OUR THROUGH THE CHAIR.
THESE ODD NO SO UNFORTUNATELY
OFF FEDERAL LAW WHICH SUPERSEDED
THERE BUT INDIVIDUAL I STILL
HAVE TO MEET THE REQUIREMENT TO
BE A REGISTERED VOTER.
ON IN ORDER TRUMP FOR ELECTED
OFFICE.
HOWEVER THEY WOULD THIS WOULD
JUST ALLOW THEM TO SERVE ON
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS SO THAT
THAT'S THE NEXUS SO AND IN ORDER
FOR FEDERAL.
THE NO ONE WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUPERSEDE FEDERAL AW AND
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE NOT NOT OF US
THAT ARE WHO ARE DAHLE
CITIZENSHIP.
IN THE UNITED STATES WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO RUN FOR FEDERAL.
OR FOR ANY OTHER TO POSITION.
ANY ELECTED POSITION YEAH BUT
THAT'S WHY IT IS THAT THAT'S WHY
IT'S LIMITED TO BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS CORRECT.
SO THIS WOULD BE MOST THESE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS OLD LIKE
ADVISORY AND EVERYONE MOST THESE
WERE TAUGHT TO BE APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR SPEAKER OF THE PRO
TIME AND SOMETIMES INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL [inaudible]
OR LOCAL.
AND SO ESSENTIALLY.
UP PEOPLE CAN ONLY OF BE
APPOINTED TO OFFICE THIRD THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE THE LAW ABOUT
ELECTED OFFICES HAS JUST
APPOINTED POSITION GOVERNOR
APPOINT A JUDGE.
WELL THE GOVERNOR CAN APPOINT
JUDGES BUT THEY HAVE TO BE THEY
HAVE TO MEET CERTAIN
QUALIFICATIONS WHICH ARE NOT
SUPERSEDED BY THIS BILL OF FINE
ON MY END CORRECT.
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WOULD
STOP TO MEET THE REQUIREMENT TO
BE A REGISTERED VOTER AND A
CITIZENS UNITED STATES. TO BE
AND AND THOSE CASES OF A
JUDGESHIP PARK SAY THE GOVERNOR
WANTED APPOINT A SUPERVISOR AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL I STILL HAVE TO
MEET THOSE REQUIREMENTS SO YOU
HAVE TO BE A U. S. NATIONAL.
USS [inaudible]
SENATOR MONNING.
MADAM CHAIR WELL I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I THINK.
AS DEFINED APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUE.
THIS BILL DOES GO.
TO BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS THINGS
THAT -- APPOINTED NOT ELECTED I
WOULD POINT OUT FOR THE RECORD
THAT SOME JURISDICTIONS DO ALLOW
LEGAL RESIDENT.
ALIENS TO SERVE ON SCHOOL BOARDS
TO BE ELECTED TO SCHOOL BOARDS
ON THE THEORY OF TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION PARENTS
WHO ARE PLAYING TAXES THEIR KIDS
ARE IN THE SCHOOL -- IN CHICAGO
THEY CAN BE ELECTED TO THE
SCHOOL BOARD LEGAL RESIDENT SO
IT'S NOT ALL CLASSES OF
IMMIGRANTS BUT AS THOSE WITH A
GREEN CARD.
SO SOME JURISDICTIONS I THINK IN
TEXAS THERE'S SOME CITIES THAT
OF DON THIS IS WELL.
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL.
BUT THE NOTION OF TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION IF YOU
WANT TO BUILD A STRONG CIVIL
SOCIETY.
INVOLVING IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE
WHO WERE LIVING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES PAYING TAXES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES -- TO HAVE THEM BE
INVOLVED AND SHARE THEIR
EXPERTISE THEIR PERSPECTIVES AND
OPINIONS -- IS HOW YOU BUILD A
STRONG CIVIL SOCIETY I BELIEVE
O I AM SUPPORT OF I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
AND GLAD -- TO MOVE THE BILL AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THE OTHER COMMENTS SEEING NONE --
SENATOR TO RUSSIA WOULD YOU LIKE%
TO CLOSE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND FOR ALL
YOUR QUESTIONS AND JUST ASK FOR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU CHAIR.
ALRIGHT THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL JACKSON HI JACKSON I WERE
JUST.
BORDERS NO ALAN.
ALLEN I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE MONNING.
MONNING EYES STERN.
I'M BURKE.
ARMORED IOWA CASKEY.
RIGHT THE THE BILL HAS A FOUR
VOTES FOR TO WIN A TWO THREE
FIVE TO ONE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO WONDERFUL
TO HAVE YOU HERE AND THANK YOU
TO YOUR WITNESSES FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
WE HAVE ONE MORE MATTER THAT IS
BY OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR
UMBERG IT'S S. J. R.. TO AND THE
IF YOU WAIT JUST ONE SECOND
SENATOR.
I MIGHT INDICATE BEFORE WE START
WITH THIS ITEM.
WE HAVE RECEIVED NO TIMELY
OPPOSITION WE DID NOTE THAT TO
TODAY.
OF THE ISSUE.
THAT THIS BILL OF FOCUSES ON WAS
RENDERED ARGUABLY -- MOVED.
A GIVEN THAT APPARENTLY THE
CONGRESS TODAY DID NOT VOTE.
TO OVERTURN THE VETO THE
PRESIDENT'S VETO AS THIS.
A MEASURE CALLS FOR SO WE DID --
TO I BELIEVE SUBMIT TO SOME
PROPOSED.
LANGUAGE -- TO A JUDGE FOR THE
EVER MOVING CHANGES IN IN.
OR A GLACIER SPEED AS THEY MOVE
IN IN WASHINGTON BUT THAT WILL
REFLECT THAT CHANGE -- WHICH IS
NOW BEING PASSED OUT -- IN --
REDID IT FOR IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND ON PAGE -- FOUR AFTER --
FORTY SIX AT LINE.
ELEVEN A IT WAS THE MEASURE READ
SO LET ME JUST IN CASE THERE'S
ANYONE THAT SIR.
WANTING TO FOLLOW THIS OUR THE
MEASURE RESOLVES OF BY THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SHORTLY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE URGES THE HOUSES OF
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS TO
SAN STAND IN UNITY AND BLOCK THE
PRESIDENT'S.
NATIONAL EMERGENCY DECLARATION
OF THIS MORNING IT CALLED FOR A
VOTE TO OVERRIDE.
BUT APPARENTLY TODAY A VOTE WAS
TAKEN THE DID NOT OVERRIDE THAT
VETO SO.
WHAT IT WILL STATE IS THAT -- AT
THE T. M. BLOCK THE PRESIDENT'S
NATIONAL EMERGENCY DECLARATION
OVERRIDING THE PRESIDENT'S VETO.
ALL OF THE HOUSE JOINT
RESOLUTION FORTY SIX AND IF NOT
POSSIBLE. TO CONSIDER
TERMINATING THE DECLARATION OF
NATIONAL EMERGENCY WITHIN SIX
MONTHS OR AT THE EARLIEST
POSSIBLE TIME PURSUANT TO THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES ACT.
AND IF I AM NOT MISTAKEN THAT IS
AN AMENDMENT WHICH A SORT OF
RECOGNIZES THAT ACTION TAKEN
TODAY BUT STILL.
BELIEVE PROVIDE YOU WITH WHAT
YOU WERE -- HOPING TO ACCOMPLISH
IN THAT AND IF YOU WOULD ACCEPT
THAT AS AN AUTHORS AMENDMENT
THAT THAT MAKES.
CONTINUES TO MAKE THE RESOLUTION
RELEVANT WOULD THAT BE THE CASE
THANK YOU SENATOR YES.
I DO ACCEPT THAT.
EXCELLENT TO THE FLOOR SENATOR
IS YOURS AND WELCOME TO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US.
AS WELL AS SENATE HUESO -- WE'VE
INCORPORATED SOME OF YOUR
SUGGESTIONS WELL THOUGHT OUT
APPRECIATED.
A COUPLE THINGS THE ISSUE OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY DECLARATION
BY PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OBVIOUSLY
VERY CONTROVERSY ALL THE ISSUE
OF THE WALL IS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL.
PEOPLE HAVE VERY -- BOTH --
STRONG AND CLOSELY HELD OPINIONS --
WITH RESPECT TO THE WALL THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT SOMETHING A BIT
DIFFERENT THIS FOCUSES ON ITS
IMPACT.
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF DIVERTING
FUNDING DIVERTING FUNDING FROM
PROJECTS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY IS DIVERTING MONEY
FROM THE COUNTER DRUG BUDGET.
EVERY YEAR THE OFFICE OF
NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL POLICY
WHICH I WAS A MEMBER -- COMES UP
OF THE NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL
POLICY INTO STRATEGY FACT MOST
RECENTLY IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN PRESIDENT I'D
STATES SIGNED OFF ON THE
NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL.
POLICY WHICH OUTLINES OUR
NATIONAL EFFORT OUR NATIONAL
STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH DRUGS.
IF YOU SEE IS NATIONAL DRUG
CONTROL STRATEGY YOU'LL NOTE
THAT NOWHERE IN THERE DOES IT
MAKE REFERENCE. TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF A WALL WITH
RESPECT TO OUR COUNTER DRUG
POLICY NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS
THAT THE A REDIRECTION OF
RESOURCES FROM.
IMPORTANT PROJECTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
HAS AN IMPACT ON US INTO YOUR
POINT MADAM CHAIR WITH RESPECT
TO THE HOUSE FAILING TO OVERRIDE
THE PRESENCE YOU THIS WILL BE AN
ISSUE THAT WILL CONTINUE THIS
WILL CONTINUE WELL BEYOND TODAY
WILL BE ON THIS YEAR.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE STANDING
UP FOR CALIFORNIA BOTH VALUES
PRINCIPLES AND RESOURCES MKE A
STRONG STATEMENT SO FOR EXAMPLE
SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE IN JEOPARDY.
SHOULD SHOULD THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY AFFECT HIS DIVERSION OF
FUNDS WOULD BE THE NAVY SEAL
RESERVE TRAINING FACILITY IN SAN
DIEGO.
IN MY OWN DISTRICT IN SEAL BEACH
THE SEAL BEACH OF WEAPONS
STATION -- THERE'S A POSSIBILITY
A HUNDRED THIRTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS BEING DIVERTED FROM THE
SEAL BEACH WEAPONS STATION --
ALSO IMPACTS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THE THE HANGAR AT TRAVIS AIR
BASE -- FUNDS A C. ONE THIRTY
FLIGHT SIMULATOR CHANNEL ISLANDS
NATIONAL GUARD STATION.
AND IT IMPACTS -- BOTH MILITARY
HOUSING IN TERMS OF LED
REMEDIATION AND OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE CRITICAL CRITICAL TO
OUR NATION'S DEFENSE AND ALSO
CRITICAL TO CALIFORNIA'S OWN.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO HAVING
SAID THAT I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TO SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO ONLY -- FORGET MANY HIVE
IN CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY -- HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF
TIME TO LOOK AT THIS JUST KIND
OF CAME ACROSS THIS MORNING --
WE DO SUPPORT THIS WE FEEL THAT
THE SENATOR UMBERG -- MAKING
THIS RESOLUTION IS A CLEAR
STATEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
IN CALIFORNIA'S POLICIES.
AND WE DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THIS REVIEW TO THE
PRESIDENT'S OVERREACH WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I WOULD NOTE THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS A VOTE OF
A MAJORITY VOTE TO OVERRIDE BUT
NOT SUFFICIENT TO REACH THE TWO
THIRDS LEVEL TODAY.
SO ARE SENATOR MINING IN ANY
OTHER.
QUESTION THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JUST BRIEFLY I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
AND I APPRECIATE.
THE DETAIL REFLECTED IN TERMS OF
POTENTIAL IMPACTS IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT MORE BROADLY -- THIS
INITIATIVE OF DIVERTING FUNDS
FROM.
REALLY NATIONAL SECURITY
PROJECTS IT THREATENS IT WEAKENS
AND REDUCES.
NATIONAL SECURITY -- THROUGHOUT
THE NATION IF YOU WILL.
IF YOU TAKE WHAT YOU'VE SHARED
IS KIND OF A MICROCOSM.
OF SIMILAR DIVERSION PROPOSED
VERSIONS OF FUNDING.
FROM PROGRAMS AROUND THE COUNTRY --
IT'S REALLY QUITE ALARMING I
APPRECIATE YOUR PUTTING A
SPOTLIGHT ON IT [inaudible]
HOPEFULLY A WISER MINES WILL
PREVAIL AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
NOT REALLY A QUESTION.
OF WHAT WHAT WHAT TO IT WELL
WELL SAID SENATOR MINING -- IT
IS TRUE THAT THIS HAS NATIONAL
IMPACT I AM FOCUSED ON
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS
THE LARGEST RECIPIENT OF OF
DEFENSE DOLLARS.
IN THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
OUTLINED THE RESOLUTION ARE
CRITICAL NATIONAL DEFENSE.
AND TO THE HEALTH AND WELFARE OF
OUR SERVICE WOMEN AND MEN --
ELITE IS.
IT'S REALLY AND IT AND IT WHEN I
SAY IT'S A SHAME THAT REALLY --
pWE'RE GOING TO TAKE MONEY AND
DIVERTED FROM.
MILITARY HOUSING WHICH IS THE
DILAPIDATED AND SOMETIMES AND
HABITABLE AND USE IT FOR OTHER
PURPOSES THAT ARE.
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OFFENSES THAT AREN'T REQUESTED
BY THE DEPARTMENT HOMELAND
SECURITY THAT AREN'T REQUESTED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THEY ARE ONLY REQUESTED BY.
PRETTY MUCH ONE INDIVIDUAL.
THANK YOU A NO THE CONGRESS I
THINK THAT'S ALWAYS AN
INTERESTING ONE NAY HAVE NOT
WEIGHED IN IN SUPPORT SENATOR
BOAR BRA.
PURCHASE.
YOUR I TO WANT -- TO COMMEND YOU --
FOR THE SPIRIT OF OF THIS --
JOINT JOINT RESOLUTION I KNOW
YOU START OFF WITH -- THE WALL
IS CONTROVERSIAL DECLARATION IS
CONTROVERSIAL AND INDEED IT IS
AND SOMETIMES I THINK WE LOSE
PERSPECTIVE -- IF THERE WERE --
IF THERE WERE WAY.
DOWN THE ROAD -- TO HELP PROTECT
SOME OF THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ASSETS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT -- I
DEFINITELY WOULD WANT -- TO SEE
THAT MAYBE CAN BE BE A PART OF
US OF SUPPORTING -- THAT -- THAT
MESSAGE -- I THINK.
I THINK THE NATIONAL DECLARATION
OF EMERGENCY.
IS SOMETHING THAT COMPLETELY
NEEDS TO BE REFINED I BELIEVE IN
THE WAR POWERS ACT.
IN THE SPIRIT OF THE WAR POWERS
ACT RISK REQUIRED THAT THERE BE
REGULAR -- REPRESENTATIONS MADE
CONGRESS THE LIMITATIONS OF
PRESIDENTIAL POWER -- WHEN IT
COMES TO ONGOING INDEFINITE
MILITARY -- ADVENTURES SOME --
IN THIS SITUATION IT'S THE EXACT
OPPOSITE WE DON'T HAVE A
DEFINITION.
OF DECLARATION I THINK WE DO
NEED ONE I THINK WE NEED THERE
TO BE TIME TABLES ASSOCIATED
WITH -- DECORATIONS LIKE THIS
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE --
THERE IS CONTROVERSIAL AS THEY
ARE TODAY -- I'M NOT I'LL BE
ABSTAINING FROM THIS VOTE ONLY
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS.
SO CLOUDED AND CONTROVERSY BUT
IF THIS COMES BACK AND OTHER
FORM AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE
WITH ANY PROPOSAL THAT --
DIVERTS FUNDS FROM OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY -- SYSTEM -- I'D.
BE VERY INTERESTED IN TALKING
WITH YOU FURTHER MAYBE IN
SUPPORTING THAT.
IN CENTER BOARD JUST -- I WOULD
WELCOME UP TO JOIN WITH YOU TO
DEFINE NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND MY
GUESS IS WE WOULD BOTH AGREE
THAT THIS IS NOT ONE BUT I
SUSPECT THAT'S THE CASE UP -- MY
UNDERSTANDING TO IS THAT SOME OF
THE FUNDING IT WILL BE COMING
FROM SOME OF THE DRUG
INTERDICTION PROGRAMS AS WELL IS
THAT IS THAT CORRECT THAT IS.
MY ASSUMPTION ALTHOUGH THERE'S
NOT BEEN COMPLETE DEFINITION
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID IS THAT
MONEY'S GOING TO COME FROM THE
COUNTER DRUG BUDGET.
OF THE COUNTER DRUG BUDGET IS --
IT IS IS -- A PRODUCT OF OUR
NATIONAL COUNTER DRUG STRATEGY
AND SO THE EXPERTS OR AT LEAST
THE PEOPLE THAT THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES OUR EXPERTS HAVE COME
UP WITH THE COUNTER DRUG
STRATEGY IN A COUNTER DRUG
BUDGET.
THAT MEETS THAT STRATEGY -- THIS
IS SEPARATE AND APART FROM THAT
STRATEGY THE US FUNDS ARE BEING
DIVERTED FROM WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S EXPERTS SAY THEY
SHOULD BE USED. FOR FOR ANOTHER
PURPOSE I WOULD SIMPLY SUGGEST
THAT THE PRESIDENT SHOULD GO
WITH HIS OWN EXPERTS.
WITH THAT WOULD BE A CHANGE IN
STRATEGY BY I THINK THIS WHITE
HOUSE BUT OF I THINK THE PART
THAT STRIKES ME WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS DRUG THE DRUG PROGRAMS THIS
MORNING AND PUBLIC SAFETY. ONE
OF CENTER BOARD USES COLLEAGUES
BROUGHT A BILL -- TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE FRONT NO PROBLEM.
WE KNOW THE FENNEL IS COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY IN MASSIVE AND
VERY DANGEROUS QUANTITIES FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD -- I
WOULD THINK THAT A IF WE REALLY
DO WANT TO PROTECT THE SAFETY OF
OUR PEOPLE WE WOULD BE LOOKING
TO FUND THESE.
DRUG INTERDICTION PROGRAMS -- SO
THAT WE COULD INDEED PROTECT OUR
OUR PEOPLE IN THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY AND IT
WAS REALLY NO DISPUTE THAT THE
THE MAJOR PROBLEM COMES FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND THOSE DRUGS WE KNOW COME IN.
EARLY THROUGH AIRPORTS IN OUR
PORTS AND IF THE MONEY'S BEING
TAKEN FROM THAT THAT FURTHER
EXPOSES.
A ALL IN OUR CHILDREN AND WHAT
HAVE YOU TO THE KIND OF HARM
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE DRUGS SO.
I AM MOST APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SPIRIT OF THIS MEASURE -- I
DON'T FIND IT CLOUDED AT ALL I
THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT -- WE
DO HAVE REAL NEED AND THE TO
THERE SHOULD BE THAT ARE THE
CONGRESS SHOULD ACTUALLY STEP UP --
STRAP ON THE SPINE AND START
DOING IN USING OUR TAX MONEY FOR
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE DOING --
THATINTO DOLLARS I CAN STILL
GET MY COFFEE IN THE MORNING I'M
SURE BUT IT IS FRUSTRATING TO
SEE AND I DO THANK YOU AS WELL
FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD SO.
THE CHAIR WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
OF MOTION BY SENATOR ALLEN THE
MOTION IS.
THE THAT THE RESOLUTION BE
ADOPTED AS AMENDED AND WITH THAT
THE MAN SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
JACKSON HI JACKSON I WE'RE JUST
[inaudible]
ALAN.
ALLEN I CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I AM MONEY.
MONNING AYE STERN.
I'M BURKE.
BURGER HI WHAT CASKEY.
CASKEY I'D.
THE BILL HAS SAYS SIX VOTES AND
WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU CENTER ON BURKE.
AND IF WE COULD IF THE SERGEANT
WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- WILL GIVE ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND GO THROUGH ALL THE BILLS AND
SNOW CENTER WHITE CASKEY IS
JOINED US WILL WILL BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON ALL THESE MEASURES AS
WELL [inaudible]
CANNELLA KID.
OKAY THE MANAGER CAN WE GO
THROUGH ONCE AND THEN SO WE CAN
GO BACK TRANSPORTATION THE STORE.
YEAH WE'RE JUST WE'RE COUNTY.
HIGH SPEED RAIL VERY GOOD SO.
CONTRARY TO THE USUAL PRACTICE
HERE WILL GO AHEAD AND RUN
THROUGH.
THE MEASURES ONE TIME TO GET
VOTES AND THEN IF WE COULD GET
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL WAIT
JUST A COUPLE MINUTES.
BUT WE DO HAVE MEMBERS IN
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL SO WE'LL
LET YOU GO IS WILL -- WELL THERE
WILL START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE VOTE COUNTY IS SIX TO ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MONNING.
MONNING I AM WHITE HOUSE SKI.
HI I CASKEY AYE EIGHT TWO ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM. ONE SB THIRTY THE
MOTION WAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATOR.
THE VOTE COUNT IS. SIX TWO ZERO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
I'M BURKE.
NUMBER BY MY CASKEY BY THE
CASKEY AYE EIGHT TWO ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM --
THREE THE SENATOR MITCHELL'S.
SB ONE EIGHTY EIGHT THE CURRENT
VOTE COUNT IS SIX TO ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS WERE
JUST.
WHAT HEALTHY HI BECAUSE HE AYE?
SEVEN TWO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR HILL THE VOTE
COUNT IS SIX TO ONE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS LIKE HOUSE HE
HI.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
AYE SEVEN KNOWS ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM FIVE SENATOR DRAWS
SHOWS SB TWO TWO FIVE THE VOTE
COUNT IS CURRENTLY.
FIVE TO ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS STERN.
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI THE HOUSE HE
AYE SIX TWO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM. EIGHT AS J. R..
NUMBER TWO BY SENATOR UMBERG THE
VOTE COUNT IS SIX TO ZERO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS LARGEST
[inaudible]
STERN.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR JUST A COUPLE MINUTES
THANK YOU SENATOR Y. CASKEY
--
AND CHECK TO SEE -- THIS SAID IS
STERN COMING BACK [inaudible]
THE WHOLE.
OF THOSE BILLS THAT HAVE THAT
ARE NOT YET CLOSED.
WE ARE ON FILE ITEM.
MISSION ABILITY OF SO CALLED
ECONOMIC DEMEANOR.
ALL RIGHT FILE ITEM FIVE WHICH
IS SB. FIVE TWO TWO FIVE THE
VOTE COUNT IS SIX TO ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS STERN.
STERN AYE RIGHT SEVEN TO ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
FILE ITEM. EIGHT AS CHAIR TO BY
SENATOR UMBERG THE VOTE COUNT IS
SIX TO ZERO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GORGEOUS.
STERN.
STERN AYE SEVEN ZERO THE BILL
ITSELF THANK YOU SENATOR STERN
THANK YOU FOLKS.
WE ARE ADJOURNED